Oh, sorry.
Dad's mad because he wants food and I'm like, right now, my chicken wrap.
Sorry, not chicken wrap, it's a breakfast wrap.
I'm like, right now, I mean, aw.
Oh, yeah.
I'm all over the place right now because I was so hungry, but like, I have like, two more dishes.
Two more days of bad eating, as in like ordering.
No, no.
He's always such a hungry boy.
He's such a fucking hungry boy.
You know what I realized?
Yesterday, he was like barking a lot yesterday.
And I was so confused.
I was like, why are you barking?
Like, what's going on?
I realized he's been barking at me to give him his meds because he wanted his meds early.
And like, you're like, wow.
I can't believe dad is reminding you to feed him his meds.
No, it's because he gets two meds, two specific medication.
One is a syrup that he really likes because it's like a, it's like a thing.
I had to do a syringe for him.
And then, and then apparently, it's like a syrupy sweet taste.
So, every time I do the syringe, he like gets super excited.
He's like, yum, yum, yum, yum.
He's like, stick it in my mouth.
Om nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom liquid.
And then the thing about his like pills, I have to put the pills in the in a tree on top of a tree.
So he'll eat it because he doesn't like eat the pill itself.
But he knows he knows he's like, well, if you want to give me pills, I need a treat on top of it.
That's right.
You better give me don't hold out.
He's an addict.
Yeah.
So then I realized because I always give him his meds at 8pm around 8pm, but he's been like barking, barking at me to give it to him earlier.
So I did because I was like, is it because of the meds?
I was so confused.
And then because I was like, why are you barking at me?
Because he was like barking at me since like 6pm.
And I was so fucking confused because I was like, you already had dinner.
It's not walkies time.
So like, I know it's not that.
And then um, and I was like, I said the meds.
And then I gave him his like, I gave it an hour early.
And in a moment, he's like, guys meds.
He's like, He's like, okay, sleep time.
He's like, sorry, sleep time.
No, I didn't do the chat over there yet because I was getting food.
Getting my food.
No, he's like, I'm satisfied now.
So, yeah.
But, I have a few days left of eating terribly.
As in, like, eating, like, takeout for a few days.
Well, to be fair, yesterday I made spaghetti.
Yeah.
I bought, like...
Daiso Daiso.
So, like, I bought these, like...
I love Daiso because you can get, like, really cheap things.
Like, really cheap things made in Japan.
And they have, like, a food section area.
So, I bought, like, these packets.
Where it's, like, pasta sauce packets.
Um, like, Japanese packet sauce.
Uh, packet sauce.
Um, sauces.
And, like, I got, like, carbonara and, um, sesame oil.
And I got, like, um, some packets of, like, you know, carbonara sauces.
And, like, um, um, sesame oil and stuff.
And I decided, oh, you know, I want to try it out.
You know?
I had them for, like, a, like, a couple of months now.
Mmm.
So, I decided to try it out.
Japanese carbonara.
I'll say, like, for those who've never tried Japanese pasta.
The way...
It's so different.
It's really different from, like, um, American pasta.
There's just something about it.
I don't know.
Is it because...
Is it because it's sweet?
I can't...
I don't know.
There's just...
It's a different taste in general.
When you try to eat Japanese pasta versus, like, uh, it's just totally different.
Especially carbonara sauce.
Like, carbonara, like, American carbonara, it's, like, super...
I guess, like, um...
What's the word?
There's, like, bits and pieces on it and stuff like that.
Like, soggy and everything.
Like, there's a lot...
Um...
There's, like, a lot of, like...
I don't know what it's called.
But, like, it even looks different.
It's chunky.
Yes.
American carbonara.
It's, like, extra chunky and everything.
But, like, Japanese carbonara.
It's more...
Iggy.
It's, like, more...
I'll just say it like that.
Ha ha ha she ba .
And...
So, it's, like, a lot different.
The taste is different.
So, I was, like, oh...
I'll try it out.
So, I made, like, last night.
I made, like, creamy-smooth.
Yeah.
It's more creamy and smooth...
Compared to, like, chunky American carbonara.
Or Canadian.
I don't know, N A carbonara.
Like say American carbonara.
I'm, like, I'm Canadian.
But...
And we're, N A carbonara.
So, it's chunky versus creamy.
Yeah, but Alexander, please don't say chunky versus creamy.
I was like, oh, that's a great description.
But yeah, anyway, last night I made some Japanese carbonara last night with spam.
I know, great comment.
Very Asian.
I fucking love spam.
Anyway, so yeah, today I ordered from my favorite breakfast place where I got, like, a booster juice, my funky monkey.
It was a breakfast wrap, and it took so long for it to get here, so I'm sorry that I started streaming late, guys.
I'm just, I was really hungry, guys.
And I have, like, two more days of, like, eating my favorite comfort food before I have to try it.
Well, I mean, I'd say I'm a fucking being held hostage, but I know it's going to be really good for me health-wise.
I saw some of the food that, like, the pictures of some of the food, and it looks really good and healthy, too.
And, like, you know, I'll be starting to count my calories a bit better, because I've been so stressed out and eating very unhealthily the last, like, month or so because of how much stress I was having.
Um, but, starting in two days, I'm eating more healthy, um, because it's, like, I think it's, like, 1,600 calories a day, um, which is, like, um, which is, like, all right, because it's, like, the lower end in terms of, like, um, calorie counting.
Um, but, like, I'm really excited, because, um, um, I don't know, the food looks really good.
The food looks really good.
It's, like, lunch.
Um, I think it's, I don't know if it's 1,600.
Maybe I'm, like, fucking making shit up.
I don't know.
I forgot.
Let me check, actually.
Because my particular meal plan, um, my particular meal plan is, like, the lower end of the calorie count.
Because I wanted to, like, focus more on health-wise.
Uh, so let me check, actually.
It is, actually, I don't, where is it?
Where is it?
I already ordered it, though, so I don't want to accidentally cancel it.
Like, I paid for it, so I'm worried I'll accidentally cancel it.
Um, and I can't say what I'm using, too, because then it'll dox me.
It is the low... Oh wait, it's... Oh, I shouldn't say it.
Sorry.
I'm here not to read this out.
Okay, but it is half the carbs, but more protein.
It's half the carbs though, so...
There is protein in there.
Um, and, uh, but it looks really good.
It looks really... I don't remember the actual...
I actually don't remember how many calories this is, because I can't see it.
I can't... it doesn't... I can't see it, guys.
It won't let me look at it anymore.
It had the thing.
It had it when I ordered it, because it was like, uh, what type of... how many calories would you like per day?
And I was like, this amount, because it gives you, like, various choices.
And I was like, this amount.
And they're like, okay, uh, we'll send this amount.
And I'm like, yippee!
Um, uh, but yeah, but, like, because I was like, 1600 is not a lot.
I was like, maybe it wasn't 1600.
I don't fucking know anymore.
Maybe, yeah, maybe, uh, maybe it wasn't.
I don't know.
I might be making shit up.
I just know it was at the... it was the lower end.
Um, because I was doing a calorie calculator counter thing.
Um, just to be like, oh, what do I do to make myself healthy to, like, starting to be more healthy for this last half of the year?
Um...
I figured it was a...
I figured it was a good step in the right direction.
Because I haven't been eating very healthily.
I mean, I'm...
The thing about me is that I try to eat healthy.
But, like, it...
Oh, 1600 is okay?
Okay, maybe it was 1600 then.
Yippee!
But, um...
Um, but anyway...
Uh, what was I gonna say?
Oh, yeah.
Like, I always try to eat healthy.
But it comes in fat...
Like, comes in waves.
So, like, I would at one point, I'll be like, Okay, I'm gonna start eating salad more.
And then, like, I just stop.
Because I have to order new groceries.
And then, um...
And then I got...
I was like, I'm tired of salad.
I want to eat something else.
And then I start...
And then I'm like, you know, I'll just eat bread.
Bread and some free cheese with some deli meat.
And then I do that.
I was like, that's pretty healthy.
And then I'm like, I'm tired of eating.
It's not fun.
And then I like, you know, I relapse into like ordering out because I'm like, I want to eat pasta.
I want to eat junk food.
I want pizza.
And I figured like, um, to resist the temptation of Uber Eats and ordering out, uh, I was like, I want to eat pasta.
I want sushi.
I don't want my sushi.
I don't want to eat fucking salad.
Yeah, like, like, I just give up very easily.
So I would go into like, you know, like random, uh, months of like eating, like, I'll go like a month of eating healthy and then I give up and then I like, I do like one, like, I'll be like, okay, this is just gonna be a cheat day.
I'll just have a cheat day.
You know, like, it's just one day.
And then and then that one day turns into two days and then that and then three days and then three months pass.
And I'm like, oh, my, my, my, um, box of, uh, unopened box of spinach lies in my fridge for three months now.
I am like, actually, I wish I was joking, but I do have an unopened box of spinach in my refrigerator for at least like two months and I haven't done it away.
It's like judging me.
And then the worst part is there's a box of pizza underneath that box.
There's a, there's a pizza box underneath the fucking box of spinach.
Forever judging me and knowing what I did.
It sees me, it knows.
Anyway, so yeah, so I hope that by doing like a meal plan where every day they deliver me like, um, a prepared meal every day, um, that I would actually follow, follow in terms of like eating healthy again and not ordering out anymore.
Well, I won't say I won't order out anymore.
I feel like I will have like some cheat days, but I feel like it's a lot more healthier because like the meals are definitely a lot more, like there's more variation with the meals itself.
And, um, and, uh, you know, like, it's, it seems like they know what they're doing.
Like, it's like a, not a big, right?
Like, it's a big brand in Canada from what I've read about.
So it's like well known in Canada.
And like, uh, it's easier to stick to.
Yeah, it's easier routine to do it too.
Uh, so I'm hoping that, uh, that that will help me.
Um, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's a tip from someone lost with Team House.
Keep a daily record to keep track of your health goals.
The start being healthy is hard, but it gets easier to longer stay on it.
You can do it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fools, welcome to Team A The Fire.
Welcome.
Yeah.
Um, is that?
No, it's not because it's like well known in Canada.
Like the, from what I researched, it is a well known, it's in several provinces basically.
Like they do, they operate this in several provinces.
So it's not just in my province.
Um, uh, so it's not like a doxing thing.
Cause like I did research for one and like, like I said, I feel like I've been like very unhealthy for a while now in terms of like, um, just not eating very healthily.
Uh, which is not good in general.
Uh, because like I've been very tired lately.
Um, I've been trying to, but to be fair, I always like forget to do a routine with my vitamins and stuff.
So, uh, I haven't been like eating my vitamins as well.
And, uh, and, uh, you know, I've been like super like overworked in the, lately because of like all the stuff that was going on.
Um, but I'm much more like this month right now is much more relaxed now after my birthday stuff.
It's definitely much more relaxed.
And, um, I have a lot more, uh, I have a lot more, um, time to focus on myself and on myself now.
And, uh, and yeah, like recently in the last couple of days, I've been sleeping earlier and earlier.
And like, I, it's so hard for me to stay up.
So I feel like I just need to start, um, doing like baby steps in terms of, uh, uh, in terms of just like focusing on myself and my health now.
Uh, but yeah, I hope this, this is a good first step for me.
Uh, oh yeah.
Okay.
I've, this is that, I wanted to tell this story because I thought it was fucking hilarious.
Um, before we played a game, but, um,
anyway, so, um, so I got a text message from my old place.
I was very confused because I haven't been there for, I haven't lived there for, um, a year, uh, more than a year now.
And, um, they're like, pick up your package.
We received your package.
Can you please come over and pick it up?
I was so confused.
I was like, I don't have any, I didn't send any, I, I, I, all this stuff that was at my old place.
Um, for delivery, I picked it up.
I, there was only one time where I had something sent to my old place that I didn't, um, that forgot to forward to my new place.
And I picked that up like beginning of the year, but for some reason, um, something new was sent over.
So I was really confused.
I was like, why was there something new that was sent over?
Like, that's under my name.
So I went over and I picked up the package.
And I was like, yeah, I like moved out a long time ago.
I don't know why I had this package.
And I opened it up.
Okay.
Okay, I feel like if I say what it is, people will be like, what?
But I'll give some context.
Before I say what it was.
So, um, but I realized when I opened it up, I was so confused.
Because I was like, I was like, I never ordered this.
I was like, why would I order this?
Okay.
So, before I say what the item was.
I, when I, I realized that I was so fucking confused.
And I was like, and then like realization came out.
Realization hit me as to how it came to be.
And I logged.
Okay.
So, I forgot.
My throne account was still around.
All right.
Well, now that you know this context.
So, I opened it up.
And it was lingerie.
And then I checked my throne account.
Because I was like, this is the only thing I could think of.
And a fan.
I think.
I don't know.
A dragoon.
Sent in.
A surprise me gift.
And it was lingerie.
I was like, I checked my email.
I checked my email.
By the way, the last time this throne account was active was February, 2024.
So, somebody actively looked for my throne account.
Last, like, at the end of June.
This year.
June, 27th, 2025.
And when it made me lingerie.
I have an option on that account.
Where the fans can buy me surprise gifts back then.
And then I checked the throne account.
And there it was.
Because you can reveal what the surprise gift is.
Because you can reveal it to yourself.
It won't be like actual surprise surprise.
Because there's an option for you to like click on it.
And it'll show you what they ordered.
And there it was.
The lingerie.
That's...
Yeah.
It's...
Oh, my God.
It's right there.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And I was just...
So, I was just like, what the fuck?
So, you can tell why I was so fucking confused.
When I...
When I received it.
By the way...
The lobby of my old place.
Because I did not think it was lingerie.
So, the fucking receptionist...
Saw me open it.
In front of him.
And I...
I was just like...
I...
Because I...
By the way I think...
Malathar, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Quick, Dragon Spire.
Like, the thing is...
There was nothing in there.
Except for that.
So, like...
I...
I was like, who sent this?
I was so confused.
Because it doesn't tell you it came from Throne.
It doesn't tell you.
Literally, you open the package.
And that's all there is.
It had zero context.
That's the word it was from.
So, I was so fucking confused.
And I was like, in my head, just being like...
Who fucking sent this to me?
Oh my god.
I...
But yes...
That happened to me yesterday.
I was like...
I was like, oh my gosh.
Oh, I don't live there anywhere.
But I can come over.
Like, right now.
Let me pick it up.
And oh my...
This is...
I paid...
I paid $20 of Uber.
I paid $20 of Uber fees.
Go there and back to pick the package up.
So, who was it?
I demand my $20 back.
Bacon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I spent $20 of Uber fees to go there.
And back to...
All right.
So, that was...
My day...
Yesterday.
Kevin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A weird dragon does that for creepy reasons.
A cool dragon does that because they know you'll rant about it on stream.
And it will be funny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Here's your Uber fee back.
Thank you.
Thank you for the reimbursement of my $20.
Michael, I love how the...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love how the first thing most dragons say is...
But did you wear it?
No.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Chee, thank you for the super chat.
This is the reason you're eating healthy.
Push, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He could be any of one of us.
He could be you.
He could even be me.
Pungun, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It wasn't me, but this story was worth at least $20.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
$20 for laundry sounds like a good deal.
Thank you.
All right.
All right, guys.
George, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hope that bro do it again.
It looks nice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's play my Storage Wars.
Yes, we never expected the story on my Storage Wars... Storage Hunters Simulator.
Alright.
I didn't send it, but I'll give you 20 dollars to show us what... Oh, you can see it on my throne.
Don't...
It's there.
He can see it.
We'll never know who sent it because it's from anonymous.
But you can see it on the throne.
The exact item that was sent to me.
Let's see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Someone found it.
Someone looked up the throne and instantly went, Jesus.
It could be any one of us.
He might be here...
He or she might be here in this chat right now.
And he...
Knowing exactly what they did.
And they're recent, too.
Because apparently this was sent during...
There was a spot on the 27th of June.
Um...
Sajan, thank you for the super chat.
Super sticker.
Thank you.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Okay.
Put the black one or the white one.
No comment.
If you were the dragoon that bought it, you answered them.
You can answer it.
The dragoon that bought it.
Alright.
Only they know what color it was.
Let's see.
Um...
For those who don't know...
The...
What storage...
Uh...
What storage hunter is.
I think it's an American thing.
I don't know if they do this in any other country.
But like...
Uh...
People would buy like...
Storage areas to...
Place stuff.
Um...
Like...
Place like items that they couldn't...
Like if they're moving or something.
Or they're placing items.
Um...
Uh...
Extra items and stuff.
They store it there.
And if you don't pay...
If you don't pay the...
Uh...
Fees.
Um...
Each month.
Or like...
I don't know.
Each year.
To house your items.
They would put your storage...
Up for auction.
And then like...
We...
Are the people that would be...
Uh...
Yeah.
They're considered abandoned storages.
Cause you don't pay the fees...
Rent fees anymore.
Um...
You missed out on paying the rent fee.
And so...
They auctioned them out.
And then like...
We are the people that are trying to...
Buy...
Cause we don't know what's in those storages.
So they'll like...
Be like...
This is storage 576.
Um...
We'll start the bidding at like...
Five dollars.
Or some shit.
And then like...
After you buy the storage...
They open it.
And like...
Let you see what you get.
Basically.
And then everything that's in there...
We get to keep.
It's like...
IRL gotcha.
But with people's belongings.
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do we get to...
Drive me if you want.
I won't stop you.
It's a free country.
Yeah.
It's like a...
IRL...
The original...
Gotcha.
Yeah.
IRL loot boxes.
Alright.
Uh...
Moderate risk.
Ooh.
Let's do it.
We love a good risk.
Alright.
Let's be...
Who do we wanna be?
Alright.
Let's look like...
Moody plumbers.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Let's be a dragon.
Wait.
We don't have a yellow skin color.
Okay.
Nevermind.
This is...
Jeff Bezos.
Hahaha.
I guess we just...
We're just Jeff Bezos now.
Isn't this his current?
No.
He's...
He's beardless at the moment.
Alright.
We're Jeff Bezos.
Don't worry.
We're gonna make it big.
Before...
Before Amazon.
We were...
We were storage hunters.
Alright.
Summer event.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
There's exclusive summer outfits.
Guys.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
I can build...
No.
Don't put me back in Scandinavia.
I don't wanna build my own car again.
I...
Please.
Not again.
I can't go back to Scandinavia.
I...
Uh...
Oh...
Hosni.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not to nitpick.
But aren't gifts from that throne account technically supposed to be for dad?
I don't know if he could fit...
With the laundry.
Guys.
I...
Hahahaha.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, how do I... Press tab to open or close your tablet.
Open your tablet and sign up for the auctions in Blueberry.
Oh, right?
Auctions.
Oh, okay.
I have to go to Village People, opening price.
Alright, nice.
Take the car, enter, drive, and win my first.
That's right.
We're gonna make it big!
I have one vehicle taking out at a time.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah.
Aw, man.
Guys, I might not be rich now, but just you see, I'm gonna win... I'm gonna win the biggest auction of my life.
Yeah.
A big one.
And then you'll all regret making fun of me in high school.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the auction?
Oh, let's turn down this whimsical storage music.
Okay.
Let's turn this down.
Alright.
My copyright-free music right there.
We'll gamble it all.
The first garage, the first storage unit is always the best one.
Oh, wait.
How the fuck did I get there?
We're off-road, baby.
Yeah, where we're going, we don't need no roads.
Off-road time.
But I'm on-road.
Alright, I'm here now.
Alright, I'm ready.
Use the W and S key to select the amount.
To bid, press the E key.
Hold it down.
Alright, where's the auction?
Alright.
Sign me up.
Please be on time.
I'm ready.
Where is it?
I'm ready to win my first auction.
Oh, it's over there.
And then I'm going to get my mid-conditioned N64.
Here I go.
You're all going to regret it.
You're not getting this beautiful store.
Oh, yeah.
You get like...
Okay, that's...
Okay.
Wait, this is... This is not how it's done in Storage Wars.
Storage Wars?
Why am I able to see... Oh, but there's a chest right there.
Wait, there's a chest.
Wait, that might be good.
Yeah.
Give me that chest.
There's a chest right there.
It could be... There could be actual treasure.
Oh, really?
Don't worry, I can afford it.
That's right.
Going once.
I did it!
I won!
No!
Alright, what did I get?
Hold down on the...
You want to verify.
Instant cell?
Gym steps?
Oh, verify this.
What is this?
Verify.
I need level 2 verification!
Oh my god.
Oh, this is...
Okay.
What the fuck do I do?
I have to visit the locksmith?
Alright, let's just...
Verify this right now.
Okay.
That's fine.
We can fix it.
I need a fixing tool of level 2.
Okay, we sell this.
That's 4 dollars.
That's 2 dollars.
That's 1 dollar.
Alright, let's verify this.
This seems rare.
Okay, 65 dollars.
Okay.
I need verification.
What about this?
12 dollars?
Oh my god.
How do I get a...
Okay.
Oh.
Pack items.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna...
We can...
We can salvage this.
I'm gonna...
I'll fix you.
I will fix you.
I'll make you better.
Don't worry.
I can fix you.
How do I...
Okay, wait.
Okay, we gotta be able to pack this up.
Don't worry.
I'll fix you.
I'll fix this rusty ladder.
You can unrust anything.
Okay, wait.
What's this?
What is this little shit?
Why is it all broken?
Wait, this is...
This isn't even broken.
Where are you?
No.
Okay.
We have...
Two dollar profit.
Let's go.
Look at that.
See, a profit...
Profit is profit, guys.
Profit is profit.
Alright, let's bring you over to the pawn shop.
Jedi storage.
For each other.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
Eventually, I'll have like a thing that can help me and move things faster.
We gotta sell this, though.
Oh my...
Look at that.
Ten dollar profit right there.
It's...
That's almost ten dollars.
Okay.
I can fix you.
Don't worry.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
I get my gas all natural.
I don't pay for gas.
Ha ha ha ha.
Uh...
Juan George, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I used to have one storage space and I was too lazy to clean it when I moved.
So the storage guy just telling me to leave it and they can auction.
P.S.
It's full of my old techs for that stuff.
Wait a minute.
That sounds like a scam.
Ha ha ha ha.
You have rare items verified each expert and is responsible for verif...
Okay.
All right, we just got...
Wait.
Wait a minute.
You knew what was inside that storage.
Ha ha ha ha.
You knew exactly what was inside that storage.
That poor guy that won textbooks.
Ha ha ha ha.
Okay guys, I played Tetris.
And it all fits.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll just leave this here for now.
I'll come back for you.
This is like the 600...
665 dollars one.
Okay, so we gotta...
No!
Oh wait, that's fine.
Wait, what's that?
Did I steal this?
Oh no, it's okay.
You didn't see.
There was no cameras.
You don't know.
No one knows.
Don't...
They won't know.
No one will know.
All right.
So we gotta go find someone that can unlock...
Okay, that's for cars.
Okay, that's the locksmith over there.
But I'll go to the locksmith.
All right.
This could be something very special.
What's in this?
Select item.
Okay, it's only a...
It's fine.
It's only 20 dollars.
There could be a treasure map in there.
There could be an N64.
You don't know that.
Oh my god, I could buy a gun.
Okay, wait.
I need to find a place to buy my fixing tool.
Rifle, swords, and clothes.
Buy, sell, trade.
It could be my Pokemon cards.
Guys.
I'll be one of those people that have no idea what Pokemans are.
But I'm here to scalp them.
Where is?
Oh, so how's the music now?
Sound guy.
Okay, local pawn shop.
For real.
There's like, scalpers that, like, clearly don't know anything about, like, Pokemans, but they're all buying up all the fucking Pokeman cards.
That's me.
That's going to be me.
That's right.
I'm going to Walmart.
And I'm going to Walmart while they're stocking up those Pokeman cards.
And buying them all.
Alright.
Assist quality is bad.
Quest complete.
Okay, we'll sell these and then I'll fix the gym step later.
You can sell verified items at the pawn shop.
Okay.
Alright.
What is this?
Don't worry, I'll fix you.
You don't know what's good.
Think about the children.
Think about my paycheck.
Alright, let's go back.
I need to go back.
People still scalping.
Yeah, I was so surprised that Pokemon cards...
Sorry, I got into the bit too real.
It got too real.
I was so surprised that, like, Pokemon cards got, like, became a thing again.
Like, the scalping of Pokemon.
But, like, it got worse.
Because I remember when, like, Logan Paul did that whole, like, like, um, unboxing shit.
And that, like, set off, like, a huge fucking trend of Pokemon cards unboxing.
And prices started surging.
And then, like, I was so surprised it, like, happened again.
I don't even know what triggered it.
Oh, it was, like, the Evolution card packs that triggered it or something.
Yeah, it, like, things went even crazier.
Because you would think that things were, like, crazy during the COVID times.
Because, like, people couldn't, like, had nothing else to do.
So they were just, like, opening Pokemon packs.
But now it's, like, even worse now.
Can I buy a gun?
Wait, this is...
Oh, fuck it.
I'll just sell it for now.
Fuck it.
I have a good rep now.
Can I buy anything else?
No, okay.
That's not a gun.
Yeah, same with Magic cards.
I don't even know.
I don't even know what trick...
Do you guys know what triggered, like, the second coming of scalping?
I think it's funny that American cards are worth more than the Japanese cards, too.
The second coming of...
Captain, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As someone currently into Magic right now, it's becoming a nightmare with this Final Fantasy wave.
Where it's pretty much the Pokemon people buying out the stores.
Yeah, because you see the money.
They're like, oh, if I can do that on Pokemans, I can do that on the Magic, the Gathering cards.
What do I do?
I need to earn money?
I sold everything.
Oh, the guy with the...
The guy that was unlocking my chest.
Alright.
Similar with, like, Garage Hunters.
The people who, like, hunt garage sales for, like...
For, like, rare finds and stuff like that.
I had, like, some of those shorts recommended on my YouTube feed.
And I swear to God, they all sound like fucking pretentious assholes.
Like...
I hate watch them.
Um...
Whenever their shorts come up, I hate watch it.
And I'm part of the problem.
I'm...
I'm part of the problem.
Uh...
They are...
They're...
The comment section is filled with people calling them assholes for doing it.
And being like...
Yeah, I'm glad the garage sale people...
Um...
Aren't...
Uh...
Aren't selling you the stuff that you want.
But then, like, we're all enabling them.
We're all...
We're all enablers.
Hello?
Just let me be part of the bid!
Oh, I have a map.
Okay.
What is this, anyway?
What's the legend?
Uh...
Okay, that's the pawn shop.
The mo...
Oh, this is where I build my car.
I guess that's for gas.
There's a locksmith.
What the fuck is that?
Uh...
Preppers?
What, for my...
Mine detector?
Oh, who's fucking putting out mines?
Wait.
New auction tiers.
New auction tier and pawn shop.
How do I fix my stuff later, though?
I wanna fix my things.
Uh...
Oops.
Oh my god.
There's even, like, a little legend thing here.
Uh...
Blueberry pawn shop.
Oh, I can buy it.
And then I'll be part...
And then I can...
Um...
And then I can be part of the system.
Artemis!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, the green spot to the left?
What green spot to the left?
Where is it?
Oh my god.
There's more?
That's the city!
Oh!
There's so much more.
Toys that make noise.
What am I gonna do with that?
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna be late.
Hello?
Where's my auction?
I saw...
Oh!
I have to stand there!
Oh, wait!
Don't start the auction!
Alright.
There's a sink.
Okay.
That has to be worth a lot.
It might be rusted.
But I think...
I think that...
That stove right there?
That has to be a lot of money.
I'm gonna bid it.
I'm gonna win it.
That's right.
Get me in there!
That's...
Get out of here, Gabriel!
I bet there's an N64 located underneath that stove!
That's right!
It's not junk!
I can fix it!
Get me in there!
I can smell the N64 underneath that sink!
That's the holy grail!
Watch this!
Okay.
Oh!
I told you!
It's the holy grail!
I knew it!
Oh my god!
And I got a...
You guys didn't see it!
But there was a chest here!
Look at that!
Oh my god!
My labubu!
I got labubu!
You all laughed at me!
But look who's laughing now!
I got a fucking labubu!
I got a birdcage too!
The fuck do I fix all these stuff?
Okay.
Wait, that's actually a lot of shit.
My rare labubu!
That...
Don't die!
My 24th care labubu!
That's right!
It's not a lafufu!
It's a labubu!
Already got my money back!
Look at that!
I already got it back!
And I got a rare ass chest too!
It looks...
I got myself some profit!
You all laughed at me!
You were like, Stop Doki!
Stop!
And I knew...
Never quit!
Winners don't quit!
Jeff Bezos never quit!
Alright!
Gotta make sure I get my labubu!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
You gotta make sure!
Gotta stay there!
Alright!
What's this?
Okay, I gotta sell this!
I'm using the force!
Maybe I'm Voldemort instead!
This is what happens after...
After the franchise died!
Ha ha ha ha!
After the franchise died, I got it!
Voldemort had to make ends meet!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
I'm a wizard!
I'm a what?
Alright!
Jeff is Voldemort!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ooh!
I didn't say that!
He he he he!
Alright!
I bet you...
My...
I'll need to get my Holy Grail!
One day!
I'll have the Holy Grail!
The N64!
Alright!
Here I go!
See...
Okay!
I can't...
I'll pick these up later!
I have too much stuff on my van right now!
Pick it up later!
I'll go and sell this!
And make my thousand dollars!
No one steal my shit!
I don't know!
Okay!
Yeah!
It's been tough for...
For...
The wizard who can't be named!
Oh my god!
Okay!
Ha ha ha ha!
I saw a really...
I saw a really fucked up tweet!
Um...
A couple of days ago!
About the...
I did not realize...
That...
Irish people exploding...
Is a very...
Is an actual stereotype...
About Irish people!
I was not aware!
Ha ha ha!
I was like...
What the fuck?
That's a thing?
Ha ha ha!
What?
I did not know...
About that!
Ha ha ha!
Yeah!
I was like...
What?
That's a stereotype?
I did not know!
I was learn...
I learned about...
History!
Oh my god!
I was so surprised!
Ha ha ha!
I was like...
Holy shit!
That's fucked up!
All right!
Let's put this stove...
It's Tetris time!
Do do do do, do do do do!
Do do do do do!
Do do do!
Do do do do!
Okay!
That's...
Nevermind!
It's not Tetris time!
It's just one item!
It's just...
It's just one!
All right, it's just one item.
My beautiful Tetris of one item.
Here we go.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
Do I need gas?
Oh, shit!
Okay, it's okay.
I can afford gas soon.
Don't worry.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
All right, nice.
We're gonna make it back.
The prize Waffle House Grill, exactly.
All right.
Okay, now we Tetris.
Oh, shit.
I'm almost back.
Don't worry.
I know there's an N64 in that chest.
Eventually, I'll get my Grail.
I'll get it eventually.
Also, did you guys know that thrift shops are, like, for-profit?
You think, like...
You think, like, thrift shops are, like, you know, doing stuff for, like, charity-wise?
But, like, thrift stores are, what are, is owned by a fucking million dollar doctor.
By a million, a doctor who's a millionaire.
It's all for profit.
Yeah.
I didn't realize that.
It's, like, people were, like...
People...
Because people... Because I was watching a short that was talking about how, like...
Um...
It's crea- Like, there was a chair or couch or something.
Like, somebody donated a $50,000 couch to a thrift store.
And this lady was, like, uh, talking about this- the item itself.
And was like, yeah, this is a- Oh, wait.
I got- I got a journal.
Oh, I'm almost there.
Wait.
I managed to- Oh my god!
He managed to unlock it!
Oh my god!
1064 time!
And then, the lady was talking about the- the chest- uh, sorry, not chest.
The, uh, the couch that- the $50,000 couch that someone donated to a thrift store.
And then the- the thrift store was selling it for, like, nine- like, $10,000.
But, like, they pocket that entire- like, they pocket it, basically.
Like, they get to keep all the money from that cell.
Which is fucking crazy to think about.
Wait, what was in it?
Where's my chest?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, what's in it?
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Are you ready?
Let's do a countdown!
Five!
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
I can't open it.
Wait, what?
Oh!
E!
Oh, okay, I got it!
What is it?
What is this?
$23?
Okay, that- okay.
Ooh, god, necklace!
That has to be- Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
I can't even verify... Can I sell the chest?
Can I...
What do you mean I need a verification tool number two?
What the fuck am I gonna do with this?
Alright, at least I paid back the... I paid the opening for that chest from my fishing rod.
Alright.
What the fuck am I gonna do with like... with like this... this chest?
I need a two-step verification!
Mage, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Alright, let's go to the pond store.
Alright, we gotta sell that chest tool.
I'll put it up on eBay.
Someone will want it.
Okay, we'll sell the fishing rod first.
I don't know what it's in here.
I gotta keep this chest.
I don't know what the fuck is in my chest.
Get out!
I'm a business owner!
I'm a future millionaire.
You don't wanna make me angry.
Alright, let's go do one more auction.
Uh, this way.
Oh wait, that's not it.
Alright.
We gotta go this way.
Alright, give me a sec.
Alright, it's...
I don't know how I... I forgot how to get to like the only source of income for me.
I think it's this way, and then there should be one more storage that I can bid on.
That's right.
I'm here for the last auction.
Oh fuck.
Never mind.
Please!
I'm $200 short!
I'm $200 short for my rent!
You can't do this to me!
Okay, where do I live?
Wait, where is my house?
Is this where I live?
Oh, I can sell it.
Wait, I wanna live here.
That's $200.
Wait, how much is my current rent?
$100?
Okay, we're not...
We're not living there.
That's...
$200 a...
$200 a week?
Wait, did I say a week?
I'm not made of money!
I'm pre-Amazon Jeff Bezos!
That's fucked up!
Okay, we'll wait...
We'll wait here until my chest is open.
Alright.
We'll wait here.
Hello sir.
Two more hours, I can wait.
This is where my money maker is.
Right here.
Right here!
I'mma make it all back right here.
Uh, James, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Uh, Xena, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The Irish Civil War.
Gee, the...
The troubles.
Yeah, it sounds...
The troubles sounded like...
Not so troubling.
Like...
You can't kick me out!
I'm not luring!
I am a paying customer!
I'm literally...
I am giving you business, sir!
So I can loiter as much as I want!
Don't make me start scalping Pokemon cards!
I'll do it!
That's right!
That's a threat!
Don't make me start scalping the Pokemans!
Oh yeah, now people are scalping the Boobooz!
Um...
There's like...
Like...
I was...
Cause like...
The Boobooz is like...
Okay, to be fair, like...
Cause...
The Boobooz have been around for so fucking long!
It's crazy how they just recently blew up!
Wait, when were the Boobooz out?
The Booboo...
When...
When were they a thing?
Cause I used to be like...
A...
Yeah, it started in...
2019!
So I've seen them around since 2019!
And...
Like...
They only recently became super popular...
This year!
Uh...
Because some...
Apparently a K-pop celebrity...
Was seen wearing them!
So the K-pop fandom...
Blew up with it!
Blew up about it!
And then it traveled everywhere...
Around the world...
Because of it!
But it was already popular...
In Asia for like...
A while!
But not that popular!
Uh...
And Popmart...
Popmart is actually...
I think like...
Popmart...
Popmart is like...
Cause the Booboo is actually from...
A Hong Kong designer!
Um...
And Popmart...
I don't know if it's like...
Ch...
It's Chinese!
Yeah!
Popmart has been like...
A well-known...
Chinese...
Uh...
Figure company since...
2010!
So I've known about...
Popmart for the longest time!
And I actually have a couple of...
Popmart figures!
Um...
When they do like...
Like the cute collection ones!
The one with the little dogs and stuff!
Um...
So...
So that...
I've been like...
A Popmart collector over the years!
But never LaBooBoos!
Cause I was...
I always thought they were like...
Pretty ugly!
IMO!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Yeah!
Uh...
They're like the new Beanie Babies right now!
And...
Uh...
I was watching a short about like...
This...
Girl...
This woman...
I would say girl...
But she's like a fucking grown-ass adult!
Ha ha ha!
Uh...
Box collection!
Like...
That's based off of like...
Pastel colors!
Cause like...
Bitches love pastel colors!
And I'm one of those bitches!
Um...
Ha ha ha!
That's right!
I'm one of them too!
Ha ha ha!
And...
Um...
They do like these like...
What is it?
Pop Mart auctions?
Where like...
Uh...
They basically like...
Pop...
Like...
The scalpers would go do an auction!
So it's like...
Alright!
Uh...
Start bidding on these boxes!
And shit like that!
To get your items!
And there's so many of them!
It's like on mo...
There's so many like...
Online...
Um...
Uh...
What is it?
Reseller auctions now!
Going around!
But you have...
You can only buy it on like...
On your phone too!
Oh my god!
Even how...
Hire scalpers to scalp for...
Yeah!
It's actually...
Influencer marketing is so crazy!
Yeah!
It's so crazy right now!
It's actually so interesting!
Cause like...
TikTok now has a section for...
Where you just...
You can auction items out!
Like...
It was like the TikTok marketplace!
Yeah!
It's like the Beanie Babies again!
But it's like...
I guess like...
Less...
Mass-produced!
Because like...
Popmark figures...
Popmark figures are more of like...
Artistic figures and stuff!
Because a lot of the...
Um...
A lot of the figures you see from Popmark...
Are like...
Higher quality...
Resin figures!
Which is a lot more...
Expensive!
Yeah!
TikTok has a marketplace!
So at least like...
The quality is better!
When I was at like a night market...
There were so many...
Like...
When I was at like a night market...
Um...
There's like...
Like where they sell like random stuff...
Like you know...
Like...
Like stalls there...
That would sell their own stuff...
There were so many stalls...
Dedicated to like...
Like...
La Boo Boo...
Accessories!
And there was one song that said, we have la boo-boos.
They're like, we have authentic la boo-boos.
Like on the side.
And then it was like, full of people.
And then songs were like, we make la boo-boo clothes, so you can like customize your...
la boo-boos with like custom made, like, hand knitted clothes and stuff.
So they can like put, like dress them up and shit like that.
There were so many.
I was like, it was crazy.
I've never had Dubai chocolate before.
I've always wanted to try it.
Alright, what's in this?
What's in my chest?
I have a football helmet.
Oh my god, this might be rare.
Okay, $19.
That's, oh my god, and a screwdriver.
Mama's making some money now.
Oh.
Okay, $6.
Wait, that's fucking it?
Wait, he's a collector.
Maybe it's like, a screwdriver from the 1950s.
Oh my god, I know what to do.
Don't worry guys.
I got a screwdriver from the war.
From one of the world wars.
This screwdriver...
I'm like, what is it called?
Pawn Stars?
This screwdriver was from what...
From World War II during the 1940s.
Where this particular screwdriver was used to make...
To make the plane that was at...
What was it?
Britain?
Uh...
Was it No Man's Day?
No.
What was it?
On D-Day.
That made the boat.
That drove to D-Day.
I know a guy.
Don't worry.
Um...
Best I can do is $5.
This screwdriver made that boat.
That drove over to Europe on D-Day.
Hehehehe.
Buy my screwdriver.
Wait, how do I make him buy my screwdriver?
Bringing up collectibles to unlock unique outfits.
The list of items.
Wait, I have a collectible!
Right here.
Buy my screwdriver.
Yeah?
Yeah!
Take it!
Take my fucking screwdriver!
How fuck do I give you my screwdriver?
Instructions unclear!
Here!
You're a collector and I have a collection!
Hehehehe.
Take it!
Okay.
I...
There is the screwdriver!
It's the same thing!
Hehehehe.
I show you my screwdriver!
Please respond!
Why?
Oh no, it's stuck now.
Hehehehe.
It's stuck.
Oh no!
No!
It's underneath the map!
My 1940 screwdriver!
It's okay.
I still have my helmet.
It's fine.
It's gone forever.
I still have my helmet.
Don't worry.
They all laugh at me now.
Wait until I invent Amazon.
Hehehehe.
My investment.
My investment!
Hehehehe.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'm gonna sell my helmet before I go home.
No!
It's closed!
Okay, I'll go home then, I guess.
Today was an...
I might...
Don't worry.
I might be short on rent.
But like...
They know...
I'll write an I.O.U.
to my...
Rent Lord.
My Land Lord.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'll be...
I'll have enough money to like...
Buy those like tools that let me see what chest it is.
We didn't lose!
The Storage Wars!
We won!
We won our two auctions!
Oh!
Rent Lord.
Hehehehe.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'll put you here.
No one will steal this.
Like, we all live in a dump.
Why would you...
Why would any of you steal this?
Okay.
There you go.
It's time to sleep.
Alright.
My loans.
Oh!
I can take a loan!
Okay.
I am paying it in.
I shouldn't.
Oh, but it's...
I...
But...
Imagine the amount of storages I can win though.
Alright.
Sleep.
Hey, all items outside of your warehouse and car will be cleared.
Every day, all items outside of your warehouse and car will be cleared.
Wait!
What?
No!
Oh my god.
They can't take it.
They can't take this.
I worked so hard!
Okay.
I'll put it in my house.
They're like decorations.
It's decorations!
Look!
It's my favorite football helmet!
And then, like...
This is the necklace that I wear.
That I wear every time I go to sleep.
No!
It said if they put...
Oh!
It's my necklace!
It said like...
This is my necklace that I got from my grandma.
No!
Don't disappear!
It says everything in my car will disappear!
No!
Don't disappear!
I'm like that Batman holding...
Holding his...
Dead parents.
Body's like...
No!
Don't leave me!
Okay.
I love this chest like it's my parent.
It's got dark rope.
Damn, Batman.
You need therapy.
Did Batman ever go to therapy?
Or did like...
Or did he just, as a child, just...
Was just rich?
Is that therapy enough?
I don't know if they ever gave Batman therapy.
Okay.
I...
Wait.
Outside of my warehouse and car will be...
Wait!
Does that mean if it's in the car, it'll be okay?
It says outside of my car.
Oh!
Is it outside of warehouse and outside a car?
Or outside of warehouse and in the car?
Like...
It doesn't make sense!
Okay.
In the car will be fine.
It's 3am.
It's okay.
They understand.
Wait, what?
What's this?
What the fuck is this?
Is that my money?
Okay.
Don't worry.
We gotta keep this chest.
It's fine.
It's Tetris again.
Doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo and that's why we don't see them as often anymore.
I've never actually seen a real firefly to be fair.
Yeah.
Yeah, fireflies are... That's why Minecraft removed fireflies.
Because they thought it was like... Also because they're poisonous to frogs, but... But apparently, fireflies are like endangered species now.
Yeah.
It's pretty sad.
I think it's like because of pesticides or some shit.
It's usually pesticides.
Wait, it's 4 in the morning.
It's already sun?
Alright.
We sleep now.
I earn... spent... Yay!
$62 profit!
Look at that.
See, guys?
You gotta... You gotta... Uh... Wait, what the fuck is that?
Holy shit.
Go, Grandpa.
Go.
You gotta spend money to earn money.
Look at him.
Go.
Oh my god.
He was a nom, guys.
Uh... He's a grown ass man that dresses like a bat to punch people.
And you think he went to therapy.
NSD.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh... Ultra.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Flashback Batman.
This is where I watch my parents die.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh my god.
Batman.
Ha ha ha ha.
Grandpa.
I got these gains, bro.
I don't need gas yet, right?
No.
I'm not wasting my money on stupid things like gas.
Oh my god.
I wasted gas.
Stupid pull.
Why did you put that there?
Alright.
I'm ready for my next storage war.
Sign me up, baby.
Or is it?
Nobody's gonna outbid me.
I know what I want.
Get me in there.
Okay.
There's another chest.
Oh my god.
There's two.
Do you see that box right there?
That's my N64.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
We're getting rich today.
Get me in there.
Fuck you, Dennis.
You don't need this.
You go to college.
I'm a high school dropout.
That's right.
Didn't Jeff Bezos dropout?
Oh no, that's like all the other multi-millionaires.
I was gonna say, like... I know, like... You know the crazy thing?
People would be like, yeah, they dropped out of college and became millionaires.
But then, like, majority of those people that do that?
Alright.
Harvard dropouts.
Like... Ha ha ha.
Like, they fucking already made it to Harvard.
Like, you're different.
You're not him.
You're... Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
It's always like... Wait, is that a... Oh, a Valentine's bouquet.
Oh, that's sad.
They're always like, yeah, but they dropped out of college.
And look, they're okay.
Yeah, because they fucking went to Harvard.
Yeah.
I had a phone.
Oh my god!
That's a phone from the 1800s.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Oh my god, those ancient phones went like... Ha ha ha ha.
This must be a phone from the 1800s.
Look at how ancient it is.
Ha ha ha ha.
You only see them in hotels now.
Is this instant sales?
Instant sales?
Kitchen module?
Look at that.
I made back my money instantly.
Alright.
The ancient Nokia from the 1900s.
Ha ha ha ha.
Alright, let's grab this phone.
Is that the first phone ever made?
I only see these in old hotels.
Ha ha ha ha.
I will put the chest here for now.
Uh... Ha ha ha.
Physical!
Look at them!
You have...
There's buttons!
Ha ha ha.
There's... There's... Oh my god.
Wait, how rare is this cowboy boot?
How do I afford verification too?
I'm putting this cowboy boot in here.
I'm gonna hoard all these chests.
Until that I can... I can, like, sell them.
Alright.
Put this phone in here.
Yep, that obsolete phone is, like, $300.
Oh, the pawn store.
This should be, like, pawn store simulator.
Pawn store and storage hunter simulator.
We got both of them at the same time.
Like, can I even... I can't even fix anything.
Like, I'm useless.
Create... I miss pawn stores when they, like... When they were, like, not assholes.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Cause that show was actually so... Cause, like... I like how it was on the History Channel.
Cause they were, like, oh, yes.
This item used to be, like, uh, in the 1800s.
Like, yeah.
And, like, they made the ghost sound, like, so fucking smart.
Like, knowing exactly, like... Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, what?
The items.
Like, back then, they used to do this and that.
I'm like, wow, he's so smart.
Ha ha ha ha.
Can't believe he knew all of these fun facts.
Yeah, it was fun.
And then he's like, best I could do was ten dollars.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Yeah, and then fucking, what's the same, Steve Carell showed up and I was like, wait a minute.
What the fuck is Steve Carell doing in Las Vegas right now in pawn stores?
Like... Ha ha ha ha.
Like, I was like, excuse me, Steve Carell?
You're not that desperate for money.
You have... You have the office money that you can live up...
That you... Oh my god.
Dude, dude...
Steve Carell literally has office, like, um, serialization money.
He doesn't need to wear your shit.
He's set for life.
Yeah, the syndication money.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
He was gambling.
Ha ha ha ha.
The royalties from the office.
Like, he could get more money.
I feel like Steve Carell is, like, one of those actors that's just doing it for fun now.
Cause he's like, he does so many, like, serious shit these days.
Okay.
Nice.
A thousand yet?
How do I have less than a thousand dollars?
Oh my god, it includes, like, money I've spent.
I'll never...
Oh my god, it's gonna take me fucking forever and make it to a thousand.
I feel like a lot of comedy actors now do, like...
Um...
Do, like, serious shit.
Alright.
Like, all the old...
Like, the old...
I, like, I say old school comedy actors.
I'm gonna make someone feel so fucking old saying that.
Steve Carell, Will Ferrell, Ben Stiller.
Like, the old classic comedy actors are now, like, going into, like, drama.
Um...
And everything.
Is this Steve Carell?
Like, almost 60?
Ben Toki?
They're, like, vintage now, right?
I love Ben Stiller's, um...
What was it?
Severin?
Severin's is...
Okay, I think...
Oh, I'm gonna refill my gas.
It's okay.
I still have some left.
Okay.
It's fine.
I still have some gas left.
Oh, my God.
Almost there.
Nice.
69.
All right.
We gotta go to a gas station.
Oh, my God.
Steve Carell is 67?
That's crazy.
I did not realize he is 67 now.
Yeah.
Ben Stiller's also old school.
Don't worry.
We'll fill up our gas.
Guys, I don't think we're ever making it to a thousand.
Nice.
Wait.
That didn't refill shit.
Okay, we'll spend half money.
All right.
And then we'll go back.
We're gonna go back.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I know where it is.
That's my money maker right there.
Don't worry.
I'll get to a thousand soon.
All right.
This is my big ticket item.
This is what's gonna push me over the edge.
Right here.
I think when I hit a thousand dollars, I can start repairing shit.
All right.
This is it.
This is it, guys.
The moment I sell this, I'll finally stop living paycheck by paycheck.
Don't worry.
We'll make it.
I'll make it back there for the second storage wars.
Nice.
All right.
And I should...
I'm not bankrupt yet.
I just need to complete this tutorial mission.
That I'm still doing.
We're almost there.
We'll progress past tutorial.
It's just a thousand dollars.
Here we go.
All right.
Coming up.
It's at 3 p.m.
Are you serious?
How would I make money?
Open the trade.
Open up.
I need my money.
Wait.
Where's my truck?
Oh shit.
It's over there.
Oh my.
What do I do now?
There's no storages for me to bid.
This is my only job.
I can't.
I can't sell any of these stupid chests.
This is gas.
This is a car.
Do I get a cell at the bunker?
I mean...
I can buy a bomb.
What the fuck am I gonna do with a bomb?
Wait.
Maybe the big city.
Maybe they'll need me there at the big city.
Okay.
There's an archaeologist.
Oh my god.
I told you guys.
I know a guy.
I...
Guys, I told you.
I know a guy.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
For the next movie.
Watch that.
Can we do the Mario live action movie?
Oh, the really shitty one?
The one that made Nintendo be like...
No more...
No more movies.
So there's that.
This reminds me of...
Like the map reminds me of schedule one.
The taste of art.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I can find...
I can find the Mona Lisa!
It's crazy that...
Uh...
Illumination...
Basically saved Nintendo and movies.
Eh...
It starts at 3...
What the fuck am I gonna do with my time until 3pm?
Okay.
I can't waste gas though.
Because like...
Gas is expensive.
Eh...
I can't believe you did it with my screwdriver from the 1950s.
A blueberry pawn shop.
I only got an hour.
You're right.
I have an hour.
I can wait for an hour.
Illumination saved Nintendo by making the Switch 2.
I still can't believe they retconned Donkey Kong and gave him pants.
In the new game.
That's crazy.
I think that one was the craziest thing.
They made it so that him wearing pants is like default now.
Like...
Only in...
Yeah, like...
In the newest game.
His default outfit is him with pants on.
The truest tragedy.
Yeah.
But you can't take off his clothes.
But then like...
The...
Description to take off his clothes like...
Judges you.
You're like...
Wow.
He's naked now.
Uh...
Like the day he was born.
And it sounded like...
It's like obviously judging you.
Like why did you take off his pants like...
Like...
Three donkeys Kong!
I...
Apparently the game...
Oh...
Uh...
Apparently the new Donkey Kong game is really good.
From what I've read.
But then the review was from IGN.
So I don't know.
I never...
The review itself is from IGN.
So like...
Is it actually...
That good?
IGN gave it a 10 out of 10.
But...
Like...
I've never trusted IGN since they said too much water.
In the...
In the Pokemon game...
That...
Was about...
Water.
That's when I stopped trusting IGN.
Sign me up.
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
Let me see.
Oh my god!
There's a dead man!
I'm bidding.
That could be a lot of money guys.
I mean that's some clout.
He might still have his wallet on him.
No way.
I'm...
They think of the potential organ.
Give it to me.
That's right!
Yes!
Going one...
No!
You bitch, Kate!
What are you gonna do with a dead body?
Oh my god.
A dead body.
I'm in.
Doki, what are you gonna do with a dead body?
Yay!
Holy shit!
I can instantly sell this dead body.
Nice.
Alright.
There's a Valentine's.
Aww!
He got rejected.
Okay.
Aww!
You know...
What the fuck?
An eyewash station.
You can tell why he died.
Aww.
A Christmas present bag.
Okay.
I need a fixing tool too for this.
And I can't open it yet.
Alright.
That's $210.
$22.
Oh wait!
Some...
That's a collector's item, isn't it?
Instant cell.
A snow tube.
Alright.
There's a...
This guy got rejected on Valentine's Day.
And now he's...
Yeah.
Look at him.
This poor guy.
How much...
How much money...
Okay, guys.
Alright.
How much money do you think I'll get from this dead body?
And then his heart broke and he was...
I can't...
Unfortunately, I can't scan him.
I know.
I have nine items in here.
Alright.
Let's see how much icky...
How much he is.
I have...
$675.
Oh, that's sad.
It's like...
Imagine being rejected on Valentine's Day and all you're worth was $1 in the end.
A whole dollar.
Jesus Christ.
Bro, it's only worth $1.
That reminded me of that time...
Like...
This guy...
This woman donated her body to science.
And then the son found out that the hospital donated her body to the military.
And then the military exploded...
Used it to test explosions.
Yeah.
It blew up the...
The fucking mom's body.
It was so fucked up.
It was like...
My mom donated her body for science in hopes that it can help the student...
Medical students there.
And then the hospital sold it to the military.
What the hell?
It is so messed up.
You don't get to choose the science.
They got...
Yeah, they got the wrong science.
Clearly.
Alright.
Buy my shit.
Oh my...
I'm gonna get it.
I'm gonna make you to a thousand dollars, baby.
Why are you laughing?
His mom got turned into a lunatic...
Yeah.
And it was actually crazy.
She thought that her body was being used for some like...
To help medical students everywhere.
Instead it...
Got sold.
That's like crazy.
What's this?
Halloween haystack.
Yeah.
I can donate it to the horses.
Oh my god.
I need a bigger car.
A hat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Almost as funny as that time when the hospital sent the son a huge bill for transportation costs.
After his son donated...
After his mom donated her body...
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Actually donating your body...
For the sake of science.
And then they're like...
Alright.
Here's the bill.
Your mom was not worth that much in scientific discovery.
That's actually insane.
That that's...
Happened.
I didn't even know about that.
Oh my god.
This is the fucking...
Crustiest...
Fucking beach...
Towel ever.
Yeah, I can Tetris.
Actually...
Yeah, I can...
I can Tetris this.
For those of you who aren't American...
And don't know about this...
But like...
Even like...
Ambulance rides...
You need to pay a bill...
For ambulance rides.
And they're like what?
Four figures or some shit?
So some people...
If they're in like an act...
If they're like...
I don't know...
Bleeding or something...
You know...
With like...
A sort of...
Like...
Major injury...
And they're bleeding out...
Some people...
Or like...
Or their water broke...
Some people will just like...
Order an Uber...
For it...
Cause it's cheaper.
I read stories of people ordering Ubers...
Uh...
Ordering Ubers to the hospital...
Cause it's cheaper than getting an ambulance over.
Okay...
I sell that...
And then getting the chest...
Get that chest over here.
Yeah...
Uber is cheaper...
And sometimes faster.
Oh that's...
Okay...
That's like...
Funny...
But also fucked up.
Someone in chat was like...
Oh yeah...
There was a story of a guy that got hit by an ambulance...
And then they...
Charged him!
That's actually...
That's crazy...
Imagine getting hit by...
Oh my god...
Getting hit by an ambulance...
And then...
You're like...
Oh thank god...
At least it was an ambulance that hit me...
And then you get charged from the ride...
Oh man...
It was an accident guys...
Like...
With a...
Crying...
The infinite money glitch...
Holy
shit...
The man...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
A body farm to watch people rot?
Holy shit...
Okay...
That's crazy...
Me...
I mean...
I guess...
Science?
I guess like...
Yippee...
Also...
I found...
Remember those like...
I recently found out...
Like...
The...
You know like those...
That famous exhibit?
Where like...
Um...
People...
Have like...
Bodies...
Like...
Being shown and stuff...
But they're all like...
Like...
I don't know...
It doesn't rot...
Because they're all like...
Filled with like...
Plasticine or some shit...
And I just recently found out...
That the owner of that exhibit...
Is a fucking crazy billionaire...
Like...
Of course like...
You know what?
I'm not surprised...
Cause like...
The idea to do that...
Had to be absolutely...
Fucking crazy...
Like...
To...
Um...
To even have that idea...
But the owner of it...
Is some...
I think he's like...
Austrian or some shit...
Um...
But he's actually...
A crazy billionaire...
He's like...
Incredibly eccentric...
And everything...
And he's like...
He's like...
Obsessed...
He has like...
He actually has...
A storage...
Filled with fucking...
Dead bodies...
Like...
I was reading his Wikipedia...
And he's...
He's like an...
He's like an actual...
Like...
Eccentric...
Crazy billionaire...
Like...
Fuck...
It's a private collection...
I thought...
That...
Body exhibit thing...
Okay...
Like...
I mean...
I don't know if he's actually...
I know he's a European...
But like...
He's like...
One of the Germans...
No...
One of the dramatic countries...
Um...
But...
I legitimately thought...
That like...
I thought...
That it was like...
An actual...
It's a private collection...
It's not even...
Like...
It's not even like...
A medical...
Like...
Exhibit...
Like an actual...
You know...
Medical exhibit...
For like, science or anything.
It's literally a...
It's his private collection.
And I was like, holy fuck.
And I found out about this, like, this year.
I went to that exhibit, too.
I actually... I went to that exhibit when I was a child.
Okay, he's German.
Okay, his name is Gunther Von Higgins.
And he's German.
And like...
He is German.
Locally source.
He's Gunther Von Higgins.
And he is an eccentric billionaire.
And...
He said...
Propond villain to your name.
There were roughly a thousand to one human bones found buried under Benjamin Franklin's house.
Thank you.
I...
Like, because I...
My parents brought me...
Brought me to see.
Because they're like, oh, this is so interesting.
Because it's a traveling exhibit.
It's a worldwide traveling exhibit.
And I thought it was like a medical museum thing.
You know, like a museum dedicated to, like, medical studies and, like, research.
But it's just a private collection owned by this man.
Because he's obsessed with plasticine.
He's obsessed with, like, putting things...
Like, preserving things.
Because he was the one that invented the technique to preserve biological tissue.
Because he invented it.
So he has a fucking private collection of this.
So I'm like...
Yes, that man actually invented it.
No way.
Like, that shit blew my mind.
Because I was like...
Alright.
Gotta take my fucking chest.
Wait, did that fall out from my chest?
Oh my god.
A medallion?
Oh, I can't even fucking verify this.
That is...
Lord is crazy.
He invented it and perfected it.
Look at my...
Jurassic Park.
I'm a people.
Mr. Broken Vaughn.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That shit, like, blew my mind.
I was not...
Oh wait, it's closed.
I was not expecting that extra lore.
You know what I mean?
I saw it.
Because I don't know.
You think that it was like an actual...
Like, you think it was a fucking museum.
Like...
Said it's owned by some fucking crazy billionaire.
Alright.
Let's put this...
One day.
I'm almost there, guys.
I'm only $101 away.
Oh my god.
I need to figure out how to fuck.
Okay.
And then I will be able to sell my chest.
I'll be able to sell this soon.
Oh, Papa Smurf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's go home.
It's time for...
It's time to go home now.
Yay.
Wait.
Is this home?
This is home.
I know.
You know what?
We made like, what?
At least $10 profit.
Look.
We didn't go broke.
That's all that matters.
We didn't lose money, guys.
As long as we're still making money...
Eventually, I'll have my big break.
I'll have my big break.
And then I can...
I got a medallion, though.
I got a medallion.
So that means...
That's big ass money right there.
I just need to be able to verify it later.
But I can't afford that yet.
So I'll save it up.
How do I buy up?
It doesn't say how I can buy up.
Look at that.
I got $87.
No, it still says the tools are not available to me.
I got $82.
That's profit right there.
It's still week one.
I don't have to pay rent yet.
No, it won't let me verify it at stores.
They're like...
Oh, we don't know what that is.
We're slowly getting...
We're surviving in this economy.
This harsh ass economy.
The Pokemon bubble burst.
So this is what I have to do now.
Alright.
Here I go.
Also, by the way...
I forgot to mention...
Regarding the lingerie story...
I...
I changed my address for it.
So it doesn't go to my old place.
If it happens again.
Because I am not paying a $20 Uber again.
I am...
If you're gonna send me weird shit...
I do not want an Uber $20.
Wait, hold up.
What happened?
Okay.
Check the beginning of the stream.
Check this...
Okay.
Tldr.
For those who are like...
What the fuck happened?
If you missed out the beginning of the stream.
A dragon...
Reminded me...
That I had a...
A throne account.
And sent a surprise gift over...
To my old place.
Right.
Thank you.
Thank you for the rain.
I'm storage hunting right now.
I've won every auction...
So far.
I'm winning.
That's right.
Get out of here, Abigail.
This is my fucking storage.
I saw an N64 underneath that shelf.
What the fuck, Mateo?
You own a suit.
You don't need this.
I'm living paycheck by paycheck.
Abigail, go back to your fucking suburban house.
Find another hobby.
Your kids missed you.
Alright, nice.
I won.
Yeah.
I got it.
I know there's an N64 here somewhere.
Alright.
I have a chemical vessel.
Okay.
What the fuck?
I need a level 2.
A chemical container.
Oh my god.
Were they making crystal?
What are all these chemical shit?
A constellation poster.
Oh my god.
They made it on this dishwasher.
$78.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
This has to be worth something.
$30.
Okay.
There is another chest.
We can also cook too.
Alright.
I found Walter's stash.
Which one was the chest with stuff?
It was this one.
No.
Okay.
It was this one.
This has a toy train.
And...
A medallion.
Okay.
That's fine.
We have...
Oh my god.
They need level 2.
That's fine.
Transport this chest.
Alright.
We're almost there at...
We almost make back the money.
$248.
Flash grenade.
Oh my god.
Okay.
The collector...
Oh, the collector would want this.
Alright.
We have a grenade.
Wait.
Actually, a flash grenade.
How much does the collector want?
Nice bomb...
AK-47.
Okay.
He doesn't want a...
Flash grenade yet.
But he will want it eventually.
I'll keep it.
For now.
I'll put in my special chest.
I have several of them.
Special chest number one.
I have a lot of special chests.
Oh wait.
Actually...
Okay.
I can sell this.
I forgot about the helmet.
Alright.
Throw it in for a little surprise.
Okay.
And then I have a chair.
And a constellation poster.
Okay.
I practically...
Look at that.
I broke even...
Oh look at that.
$2 profit.
Wait.
$3 profit.
Look at me, mom.
She said I'd be a disappointment.
But look at her.
I've made at least $6 today.
Look at that.
I ain't no disappointment, mom.
Where's your $6 profit, huh?
That's fucking right.
No ice soap tonight.
I can buy at least one chicken nuggy.
Oh, $6.
Let's go.
Alright.
Let's put this in.
And then...
What a deal.
Yeah.
Exactly.
If you bid on every auction, eventually you'll hit it big.
Guys.
I looked into that storage.
Storage.
And I saw money, money, money.
Look at that.
The bigger the item, the more money you get.
I got a fucking dishwasher.
That's the key to success, guys.
Oh my god!
Got a family heirloom.
Right there.
From the 1700s.
This necklace was worn by Abraham Lincoln's wife.
Before he got shot.
Look at that.
Alright.
Let's put this here.
And then...
That's right.
90% of gamblers quit before winning.
Exactly.
I think that's everything in that...
In that thing.
Alright.
We'll take it over to the pawn shop.
Let's go.
The best I can do is $10.
How about...
How about $15?
And you throw me in a...
A chocolate bar.
Alright.
Buy my shit.
Okay.
Chemical vessel.
Alright.
We're gonna sell this.
The necklace.
He doesn't know the value of this.
So I'm not selling that to him.
And then...
I...
Wait.
Did I sold my box?
Where's my chest?
No!
He took...
How much did he give me?
How much did he even give me?
He...
No!
That was my...
Oh my god.
How much did he even give me?
He...
Yoinked it!
He stole it from me!
He distracted me.
The world will never know.
That would have been where the N64 was!
That could have been the N64!
Ma was right.
The Papa Smurfs.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just let's do it.
He's a cat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's not true.
Ma was never right.
I'll make something of myself.
Just you wait, Ma.
Just you wait.
She doesn't know anything.
Being a successful businesswoman takes day...
Not take...
Can't just happen overnight, guys.
It takes months.
Maybe even years.
Alright.
Don't worry.
This next...
6 p.m.?
I have to wait till 6 p.m.?
Oh my god.
Maybe I'll have...
Okay, that's fine.
I'll put my...
My tre...
In my treasures.
My special treasure.
Okay.
I have...
A toy...
Okay, let's put like...
Is there anything in this chest?
Okay, there's nothing in this chest.
We'll put all my...
My special treasure in the big chest, though.
Okay, this is my flash grenade.
My little pink can.
And these cool-ass stylish cowboy boots.
Yeehaw.
And then...
I'll just put...
Stack them up here.
My family jewels.
Oh my god.
Can I put a chest within a chest?
It's like those little Russian dolls.
Oh my god.
Now we're Tetris-ing, guys.
Now we're playing real Tetris.
And...
Oh guys, I don't think I was supposed to...
Yeah, I don't think it was meant...
It's alright.
It wasn't meant to...
This game does not like that.
It's vibrate.
Guys, eventually...
Eventually, I'll complete my first mission.
My first...
The tutorial.
I will complete this tutorial.
It will happen.
Alright.
How the fuck are we gonna kill...
Time?
Oh my...
That's it.
I'm...
No, I can't.
I can't wait another day.
Because then Rent's gonna show up.
Guys, I can't wait another day or the Rent will go up.
If I pay...
Actually, maybe I can.
Okay, that's it.
No.
Not the Rent.
Anything but that.
I can't believe there's only two storages.
Hello?
There has to be another storage for my Storage Wars.
I'm addicted.
There is one more.
It is all the way...
Wait, where was it?
Pawn shop.
Taste of art.
The West Pawn shop.
Is that another storage war?
I gotta go to the next town.
I will do it.
I'll go to the next town.
That's it.
That's how dedicated I am.
I'll go to the next town over.
For my Storage Wars.
I need to storage my wars.
Honey, please find a real job.
This is my real job.
Or will we go back to the Pookie Man days?
Do you want me to get arrested again for fighting children?
I can't go back.
That's all right.
Why don't you support my passion, wife?
I mean, that was...
That's all right.
I'll go to the next town over.
And win my Storage Wars.
All right.
They won't let me back at Walmart.
Some man was trying to film me.
And I got mad.
I am a reputable business owner.
What did I do at Walmart?
They had that new Eeveelution.
Those like...
Those new Eeveelution.
Pokemon cards.
And some little fucking brat trying to take them from me.
All right.
Small...
Yeah, I know.
Small businesses are the backbone of this country.
Yeehaw.
How dare they?
How do we not know if that child was also a reseller, huh?
How do we not know?
Alright, this way.
They come in all shapes and sizes.
Where's my Storage Wars?
Wait, they're not holding any...
I literally drove to the next town.
Where the fuck is my Storage Wars?
Yeah, it could be some scalpers, child.
Oh, shit.
Blind auctions?
Oh my god, just like my blind boxes.
Oh my god, this is even better!
Sign me up!
Wait, this is even better!
Oh my god, I'm gonna get my mystery box!
Let's go!
Oh my god, $500 mystery boxes, you know those?
Oh my god, 500...
Get me in there.
600?
That's right, I have just enough.
Oh, I don't.
$991,000?!
The gambling story.
You know, remember, like, I don't know if people still do this.
But those, like, um, like, $500 to $1,000...
Yeah, of course, of course, I don't have $1,000!
Stupid Miguel.
They're richer.
Remember, like, those, like, eBay auctions where it's, like, $500 mystery boxes, haunted mystery boxes?
And, like, YouTubers used to buy, like, these boxes to unbox.
Um, and there's, like, this, this mystery box is actually haunted!
You guys remember back then on YouTube, they did that shit?
Yeah, the, yeah, the deep web mystery box era.
I got this.
It's sport category!
I have enough.
Oh, my God!
I'm...
I'm not rich enough for the blind boxes!
Even the auctioneer is more fancy!
He...
Look at the auctioneer!
He's wearing a cowboy hat!
He knows what's up!
We're too poor to play in the big leagues!
This is the fucking big leagues!
I can't afford it!
Come on!
It's military grade!
Oh, my God!
Matteo!
I remember, like, there's, like, people that actually, like, sent in, like...
They already went to a thousand?!
The big...
Bro, they're all so fancy!
This guy's wearing Beats by Dr. Dre headphones!
All I have is the one I got from...
From Walmart!
Bro, that guy seems...
He's, like, Rudy the streamer on Twitch.
This guy...
He's, like...
Yeah, I'm a...
I'm a live streamer on Twitch.tv.
Like...
You know that guy is a billionaire!
Look at his aura!
I'm out of my tent!
I...
I shouldn't even be in this city!
I'm going back to my small town!
In Albuquerque!
Turkey!
Oh, no!
And I need gas!
Okay, that's fine.
Yeah, he streamed all this, too.
I'm not...
I'm not even in the same tax bracket!
Get me out of here!
Yo-oh-oh!
I need to get gas!
Go back to poor vill!
All right, let's get the gas.
I hope the gas isn't too expensive... here.
Where you belong.
Okay, the gas is not that bad.
All right, at least the gas is not that bad.
All right, don't worry.
I'll show them.
I'll show them all.
I'll be able to afford your stupid blind boxes.
Life is hard.
I'll be a thousand dollar person only.
I'll have a thousand... okay.
I'll have a thousand dollars and I'll show them all.
One day!
I'm Solid Snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like Lil Doki, we're selling extra cards to people and then... lol, it's a... it's a cycle.
I'll be a thousandaire!
Yeah!
Then you'll all pay!
Kel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right!
I bet you haven't seen someone who owns a thousand dollars before!
Well, I guess I'll wait.
I'll wait.
Then you'll see!
And I don't trust no banks, so I'll just hide it all underneath my bed sheets.
They'll never know!
I don't need no banks!
I don't trust those bankers!
Just hide... and then I invested...
And then I invested in gold!
Cause gold... the value of gold will never devalue!
They'll never lose its value!
Alright.
Okay, here it is.
Oh my god.
I think... that coke...
Oh my god, there's a little... there's a gift box in there!
Oh my... there's two chests!
Let's go!
I'm ready!
I'm ready to bid!
There's treasures!
And a pumpkin!
There's so many mystery boxes!
Get outta here!
I waited six hours for this!
I'm locked in!
Okay!
Amber, you're here too?!
Don't you have enough?!
What are you doing?!
Leave!
Go back to your city!
Go back...
Go back to your city, Amber!
I need this!
Alright.
Okay, we have our chest here.
Okay.
I'm gonna sell this.
I have a Christmas present.
That is a little sad...
That's 57 dollars!
Oh my god!
And a Valentine's present!
Let's fucking go!
Okay, there is a 98 dollar shelf.
An 82!
Oh my god!
I'm making bake!
And a heater?!
Okay.
So these...
And then...
A beach soda can.
For 34 dollars?!
Oh my god!
Is this Coca-Cola?!
The very first time Coca-Cola was ever bottled up!
Like...
The very first time!
When they were made from real sugar canes!
The...
The crystal...
Yeah, it's Crystal Pepsi!
The original Coke with cocaine in it!
The first edition!
Oh my god!
And a Coca-Cola with Coke!
Alright!
I'm gonna sell someone's fucking Christmas present too!
What even is in there?!
I'm gonna sell my mystery!
My blind box right here!
Age like wine!
My Valentine's Day!
And Christmas blind boxes!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna make so much money!
I miss...
Oh my...
Remember the loot box date?
Like the...
The actual...
Loot Crate days!
When loot crate was a fucking thing!
There's no way loot crate is like...
A sustainable business model now!
I feel like...
That...
People have finally realized that it's mostly junk!
Like...
I used to be a loot crate subscriber!
Um...
Because like...
Every YouTuber fucking showed that shit!
And I was like...
Oh my god!
That...
That seems so cool!
It's like a little present every month!
I fell for it!
I was one of those...
I was like...
She fell for it!
And I wore it!
But it's just a way for people...
For like companies to get rid of extra stock!
So you see like...
People doing like...
Mystery bags!
Or like...
Mystery boxes!
Like...
At anime convention!
It's just...
I'm trying to get rid of like...
Extra stock!
That people don't want!
And that was me!
She fell for it again!
Alright!
I think that pushes me a thousand!
I'm pretty sure!
I think this is it!
I am finally gonna own a thousand dollars!
What if I make a loot box?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
A mystery...
...box!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Alright!
So that...
The Doki box!
Exactly!
Okay!
So this...
This...
Okay!
And then we keep our box!
And then we'll drive to the locksmith!
Alright!
Get over here!
I'm so close!
I need fifty dollars!
Open my box!
Twenty dollars!
It's fine!
Alright!
This is it!
I think the moment I sell the shelf and the table...
I'll finally own a thousand dollars!
That is my goal!
That is literally my goal today!
The moment I own that thousand dollars!
I'll be the one to laugh last!
Alright!
Okay!
This game, not gonna lie, is pretty addicting!
Ha ha ha ha!
See, this is exactly why I don't play gotcha!
I...
Had a...
A problem...
With loot box...
Loot boxes and mystery...
I actually have a problem with mystery boxes and gotcha...
And blind boxes and...
And...
Ha ha ha!
With IRL!
Gotcha!
I...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Ah!
Okay, it's fine!
It's fine!
I think if I...
If I actually...
Did like a...
A bid at a storage...
A storage hunter thing...
Um...
I think I'd...
I think I'd actually do it!
I...
I actually...
I'll actually do it!
Like...
I actually wanna go to...
NOOOOO!
My dog!
Right in my face!
No!
I can't fit the chest!
Okay, we gotta figure out how to fit the chest in!
We gotta...
He taps the side!
He...
NOOOOO!
This one's gonna be it!
How...
How do we...
Oh my god!
How am I gonna fit this?
Okay!
We can figure this out!
Oh my god!
I cannot fit two chests...
At once!
Okay!
This is fine!
We gotta figure this Tetris out!
So I can keep everything, guys!
Okay!
I put it now in here!
Maybe it'll work!
As long as it doesn't explode in...
Outside of the box!
It should be fine!
Bum ba da dum ba da bum ba da dum ba...
Oh no!
It's exploding outside of the box, guys!
It's not working!
It's not...
Working!
I can't put a chest within a chest!
The game engine won't let me!
Oh no!
No!
Okay!
It's fine!
Alright!
This is it!
And then...
I'll put this here!
Okay!
We have to put both of the...
We'll put the small chest last!
And then...
Put this here!
And then we'll put...
The bigger chest...
Bigger chest...
Oh my god!
Please!
We'll put this here!
There!
And then...
Please!
Fit!
And then...
We will put...
The shelf...
Right here!
Oh!
This is perfect!
And then...
We will put...
The table...
On top of the shelf!
Oh my god!
This is perfect!
We're Tetris-ing!
And then...
Oh my god!
We'll put...
Right here!
Oh!
It's perfect!
There we go!
We did it!
It's perfect!
It's so safe!
It's not gonna file a destination to anybody!
This is so safe!
We did it!
The Tetris is paying off!
I knew!
Instead of paying attention to the map...
And play...
And play Tetris friends!
Was a good idea!
Alright!
Wait, is it gonna close?
Is he open for like the rest?
Is he 24 hours?
I know you're in there!
Let me in!
I'm like on the...
It's like that video...
I don't know...
Is that TikTok video?
And...
Where he's like...
And the window is like...
Let me in!
I see you!
That's like McDonald's or some shit!
Alright...
No!
Not the...
Not the Eric Andre!
Like an actual...
There's an actual video!
There's an old ass video!
Of some guy!
Like knocking on the McDonald's!
And he's like...
He's like...
Let me...
Like...
Oh my god!
Please!
Please sir!
I...
Alright...
Wait...
Where is it?
This way!
It's home!
Trucks...
Trucks stuck!
But there's like an old-ass video of some guy outside of McDonald's and he keeps like, he's like knocking on the window, like demanding the employees to let them in.
That was an old-ass video.
Alright, wait, where do I live?
Oh, not this way.
Alright, it's okay.
The next day I'll be a thousand-aer there.
The next day!
Just you wait, Ma!
You didn't believe in me, Ma!
Just you wait!
I'll show Darlene.
She didn't go to the prom with me because she thought I was a loser.
I'll show them all.
Alright, nice.
Look at that!
$40 profit!
See Ma!
I made money!
Alright, that's why I can finally sell my...
I can finally sell my tables.
I'm $40 richer!
Song's up!
This is the song for a winner!
But I don't know, then they'll regret.
They'll regret it all.
They said most likely to not succeed.
I'll show them all.
Oh, it's so close.
Wait, what time does the fucking pawn shop open?
Just wait.
I'll wait.
I'll wait in my truck.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll wait.
I can wait in my truck until you open up!
I'll be right back.
I'm ready!
Take my table!
And then I can be a thousandaire there!
Alright, this...
This...
There we go.
I can buy a fixing tool!
You can buy better tools for verifying...
Fixing in the tools app.
Oh my god!
Two thousand!
Okay!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I can buy a fixer, though.
Yes!
I can fix things!
I can fix you!
I...
You guys, crazy, purple!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I can fix you!
Let's go!
The tool is a gun?
Wait, does it look like...
No, it's not.
Wait, is it?
No, it's like those, like, barcode scanner shit.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna sign up.
Okay.
It's time!
I can fix stuff now!
Open that...
Open the storage!
Oh my god, there's a chest there.
Oh my god, there's a skateboard!
That skateboard was used by Tony Hawk himself!
I gotta win that.
I can tell.
I can tell that's a Tony Hawk skateboard.
Did you see it?
Okay.
Really?
I know it is!
It's from the Tony...
Mr. Tony!
That's right!
Yeah!
Get out of there, Kate!
That...
Oh my god, Leo?
As in like...
Wait!
Isn't that...
I like how it actually sort of looks like him.
He's just there for the fun of it.
He's just people watching.
That's right.
I have nothing to lose!
Doki, this is an intervention.
You have a problem.
Push.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know there's like people who are like...
Like...
There's like people that...
Sellers hire...
To like...
Or assholes.
There's like assholes.
Or people who like...
Hire...
Specific...
Bidders.
That whole...
His whole job...
Their whole job...
Is to like...
Artificially raise the price of an item.
To make it seem more valuable.
Oh, I can fix you.
I need level 3?
For a fucking magazine?
Can I fix the hay?
Oh my god.
Guys.
Guys, this might be a...
This is not...
Guys, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I can fix this cabinet.
I fixed it.
And it's now $36.
Don't worry.
The Tony Hawk skateboard.
The Tony Hawk skateboard is gonna change it all.
This is all.
It's gonna change it all.
This license plate from...
From...
From Alaska.
That will change it all.
Oh my.
Don't worry guys.
This pad was clearly from the 1800s.
During the Victorian era.
Guys.
In this chest.
I bet you there is a...
I bet you there's a ring in there.
I believe.
Why is there a lock on that?
How do I...
Oh, is that the...
Did you see that?
What the fuck is that lock?
How do I open the lock?
It's fine.
Everything will be fine.
It'll all be okay.
It's okay.
You can buy...
It's five...
Two thousand dollars.
I can't afford it yet.
Don't worry.
It'll all be okay.
We'll be a thousand dollar near soon again.
Guys.
I have my tool.
That I can fix things.
I can fix things now guys.
Guys.
My Tony Hawk skateboard.
The value is just lost.
Because it's a little...
Fucked up right now.
It's a PSA 5.
But that's okay.
Also PSA is a fucking scam.
Use the other grading system.
But anyway.
This is a PSA 5.
So that's why it's a little...
It's a little low.
Alright.
For those who don't know.
PSA is like...
Not a great grading system.
For trading cards.
Because it's actually like...
Low key.
I wanna...
Oh, I need two thousand dollars.
If I own the pawn shop.
Does that mean like...
Like...
I don't have to worry about like...
Um...
I don't have to like...
Worry about like...
Selling things anymore.
Like...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Apparently there's a better grading system.
That actually like...
Tells you why they graded it like that.
Cause like...
People were saying that like...
The PSA...
For the PSA system.
They don't tell you why things are graded...
Like certain ways.
And instead they just like...
You can like...
Unpack the card.
And send it back.
If you think your card...
If you got PSA 9.
And you think your card is a 10.
Some people have actually like...
Unpacked the card.
And like...
Uh...
Oh my god.
It's a hand sculpture.
Wait.
What the fuck do I do?
How do I know there's a natural...
There isn't a natural hand there?
What the fuck?
I got like...
Somebody's...
Pumpkin?
It's in the art.
I'm gonna take it to the museum.
Wait a minute.
I'll take it to the museum.
Oh my god.
This is a rare find for the art gallery.
Okay.
Is the hand still in there?
Don't worry.
I'll show the snooty...
Rich fuckers.
In that city.
I'll show them.
I'll show them all.
I have real art.
Oh my god.
I'm stuck.
Wait.
There's some like PSA systems now.
That can like...
Is it this?
No.
That's the archaeologist.
Where's the art gallery?
Wait.
I knew there was an art gallery here.
What is that make noise?
Where did it go?
Oh there it is.
There it is.
Alright.
But yeah.
That actually like...
You scan a QR code for it.
And then they'll like...
Show you exactly like...
Why they gave you the grade that they've given you.
I'll show you.
I have real art.
That's right.
You snooty...
You snooty guys!
Look down on me!
But now I have art.
I have art in my hands.
I got a hand.
A little hand.
I'll show you all.
Let's go.
Real art.
Man please.
This is art.
I got them's art.
I bet you this hand was made.
By the Leonardo Da Vinci.
Alright, it's this way.
Where is that art gallery?
Now, I shall truly be a thousandaire!
Hello!
Miss art gallery own it!
Oh, it's this way.
Hello?
What have you got?
Wait.
I got this.
That's right.
Real art.
Verify.
That's right.
Real ass art.
You didn't think I would earn something as valuable as this.
You look down from me because I live in Poresville.
But look at me now.
Look who's looking down on you now.
Miss Snooty Miss Snoot.
I have real ass art.
I can wait, guys.
I can wait.
Also, it's a very long drive back.
I don't want to...
I don't want to drive back.
It's so far away.
It's so far.
I can wait.
I feel like... No!
No!
It's... It's... The hand was sculpted from Leonardo da Vinci!
Um... He's, like, gay, right?
Like, he... Right?
It was, like... I don't know if it's rumors or, like, true or not.
He surrounded himself with a lot of...
What have you got?
Male assistants, like...
What?
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, there was a rumor...
That, like... Um... That he's, like... He's, like, gay.
So, like... I was gonna say...
That hand was sculpted!
Um... From one of his... Little boy... Little... Wait.
No.
Don't say that.
His... His... His... His older assistants!
I... Sorry.
I caught myself.
I was, like, oh, my God.
That sounded so wrong.
That sounded so bad.
Chill.
Sorry.
From his... From his assistants.
From his men... Assistant men!
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Oh, there.
I stopped myself.
I stopped myself before I said something bad.
I...
Accidentally.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
It was... Big strong men of self... Male assistants!
That's right.
That hand was sculpted!
From one of those big strong ass assistants!
I succeeded in my QuickTime event.
Don't worry, guys.
I made sure to not fail my QuickTime event.
I mean, wasn't that why he liked sculpting, like, naked men all the times?
Was that Michelangelo?
I don't remember.
No, no, that was Michelangelo.
Michelangelo's the one that did the David and Goliath statue, right?
Right?
I wonder if someone's like, are you guys talking about teenage mutant?
This is not the teenage mutant ninja turtles I grew up with.
The turtle?
It's Aritoki.
It was Aritoki.
You don't understand, Aritoki.
Cowabunga, dude.
Remember when PSA gave Tyler the Great Warrior a one-of-only kind make-a-wish card a 7 out of 10?
Did they actually do that?
Bro, Dan, I don't like PSA.
Kong, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is she done?
It's only an hour left.
That's actually fucked up, though, that PSA did that.
It sounds like PSA.
Yeah, I don't like...
I like the stories I hear from PSA.
And how, like...
I don't know.
Like, I feel like, you know, it makes sense for them.
What's PSA?
For those who don't know what the PSA is, they're like the card grading company that everybody uses.
So, like, if you get a PSA 10 or something, then you can sell it for a lot of fucking money.
But they're, like, the go-to card grading company if you're a scalper or, like, you know, a card collector.
And you want to be like, oh, my card is, like, the best card in the world because it's a PSA 10.
And they grade the conditions of the cards and stuff like that.
But they're so...
They're so...
People think it's, like, super random because they don't tell you why they grade the card the way the grade is.
But there's other grading companies that actually use, like...
That are much better.
That even tells you...
Like, they'll give you, like, play-by-play on why a card would get a grade.
Mostly scalpers use it.
And I'm one of them!
That's right.
I've got, uh...
I've got my Pokemon Charizard card.
PSA 10 from one of them.
That's right.
Apparently, Magic the Gathering cards are also getting, like, fucked up, too.
But...
Which is surprising to me.
Because everyone always complains about the Pokemon scalpers.
But Magic the Gathering cards are, like, um...
Are also, like, um...
Getting fucked over now.
I also recently found out that Yu-Gi-Oh!
was supposed to be a parody of Magic the Gathering.
And that...
And, uh...
And I recently found that, uh...
Found...
I recently, like, found out about it.
And, uh...
And, like, Magic the Gathering tried to, like...
Make a...
What is it called?
Is it Duel Masters?
And Duel Masters is actually owned by Magic the Gathering.
I did not know that.
Yeah.
Duel Masters is owned by Magic the Gathering.
And Yu-Gi-Oh!
was supposed...
Supposed to be a parody.
Uh...
Of Magic the Gathering cards.
I thought Duel Masters was, like, its own thing.
Oh, how much money did I make?
You just graded it.
Oh my god!
A hundred and sixty dollar Roonies?
I'm rich!
Eighty dollars?
This statue was carved by Banksy.
We're rich, ma!
We're rich!
Alright, how do I go back?
I got a...
A Banksy original!
Oh, where am I driving to?
Oh no, I'm stuck.
Okay, it's fine.
Wait, this is not the way I have to go.
How do I go home to Portsville?
Alright.
Here we go.
We eating good tonight, boys!
Duel Monsters was...
A dream called Magic and Wizards in Volume 2.
Yeah, because, like...
Rather than...
Yeah, because it's apparently, like...
Yu-Gi-Oh!
was not a card game at first.
It was, like, a...
It was a...
Just, like...
Oh yeah!
Yu-Gi-Oh!
was...
Psychopathic.
Or sociopathic at first.
Not the...
The child, but the...
The Egyptian guy.
He was...
He was, like, an actual, like...
Psychopath.
In the original manga.
Yeah.
Yami Yu-Gi was actually very evil.
I remember.
Because, like...
He was gonna burn someone alive.
He was...
He...
In the original...
In the original manga...
Uh...
He...
There was...
There's a scene...
A famous scene...
Where he was actually gonna burn someone alive.
For, like, losing a game.
And he's like, It's just a game.
And then...
Oh, he did?
Oh, okay.
He did.
He actually did it.
He's like, It's a real shadow game.
Yeah.
And he put Kaiba in a coma, too.
And they're like, Wait a minute.
This card thing...
Is actually making us a lot of money.
Yeah.
Children.
Maybe we should make the...
Make it more kid-friendly.
And then they realize that...
When they geared towards kid- A kid-friendlier version...
Um...
They started making even more money.
Gotta love season zero.
Maybe a little less murder.
You know what?
I'm happy with our progress, dude.
Let's sell our...
Million dollar art collection.
And then...
Call it a day.
Bring back...
Evil...
Evil Yugi.
He was like...
The Joker.
Egyptian Joker.
Alright.
Wasn't there a spin-off of that...
Of that...
Stupid...
Dice...
Dice game that they did?
It's not stupid!
You just didn't understand the game, Doki.
Doki.
Yeah.
Dungeon Dice Monster.
They tried to make Dungeon Dice a monster.
Yeah.
And then it died.
They're trying to make it a spin-off of Dungeon Dice Monster.
Where's the gas station?
My car is not doing so well.
It's here.
Slander.
There was a real strategy.
It was dope as fuck, Doki.
You're just a hater.
Just a guy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kaiba also hired an axe-wielding serial killer to try and murder Joey on live television towards the end of season zero.
What the fuck was going on?
Alright.
I think...
This is a good time to call it.
I think I did okay today.
You know what?
That was a fun game, guys.
I think this is a good time.
I didn't even have to pay rent.
I never made it past the first week.
But there is surprisingly a lot of content in this game.
In this simulator.
I was not expecting it.
I reached my goal.
2010, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ironically, someone did get roasted alive for losing game two in season one.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, not exactly.
Oh, I already read that.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ultra!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was bored so I decided to buy your hot case and make something with it.
I look forward to seeing end results.
Thank you for the super chat, Ultra!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, I can't wait.
I hope you post bonus of the results, guys.
But yeah, you can still get my PC case at the Hyatt store.
I'm gonna call it here for the game.
Let's swap it off real quick.
That was fun, though.
I had a lot of fun with that one.
I just wanted, like, a one...
You know, like...
Sometimes it's, like, really difficult to find one-off games these days.
So it was cool that I found them.
It was, like, on the new one trending.
So I was like, let's try this out.
But it was really fun.
We had some crazy topics, too, today.
We had some crazy fun facts today.
But we do have another stream later tonight at 9pm.
Where we're just gonna help me plan my vacation.
I don't know when I'll be taking my vacation.
But I just felt like it'd be cool to just, like, plan it out.
So I won't be confused on what to do when I'm there.
Uh...
Yeah, let me look through my super chats.
Yeah!
Oh, I never saved game, guys.
I...
I just realized, like...
They don't have autosave in this game.
Hahaha!
So I went save game.
It was literally empty slot, empty slot, empty slot.
Hahaha!
But I saved it.
Don't worry.
I saved it, guys.
I was there.
Uh...
But yeah!
It was...
It was just fun to...
Um...
Just, like...
Just play a casual game.
And, uh...
Hang out with all of you guys today.
Uh...
It was a nice one-off.
Yeah.
Um...
Cause it's so hard to find one-off games these days.
Especially for this time slot.
Uh...
Cause I know, like...
This is a more EU-friendly time slot.
Um...
So, like...
I'm trying to find games that are, like, more...
You know, they're not...
Not too boring to play on stream.
And also, like...
Usually I try to avoid starting a new series at this time slot.
Cause I like putting...
I like starting a new series at 5.
My usual...
My NA time slot.
And then, like, if it's a long...
If I want to do a long session, then I'll, like, start at 1230.
Um...
Yeah, so...
It's one of the more, you know...
More EU-friendly ones.
So, sometimes it's my...
Hard to find...
Hard to find games for this time slot.
But I'm glad I did.
Um...
I'm glad we tried the Storage Hunter game.
Cause that was really fun.
Um...
Yeah.
Uh...
Yeah, cause that...
You know, sometimes I don't want to play a series.
And I just want to chill.
Uh...
Alright, let's go...
To...
Superchats!
Today's a wild day.
I was a little entrenched today.
Haha!
Uh...
Seijian, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yo!
Um...
Angrius, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have you set up the exercise bike machine?
No, it's still...
Um...
It's still just, like...
Up against the wall.
Um...
At my hallway.
Uh...
Hahaha!
Cause...
Cause it's so...
Heavy!
It's been...
It's been against...
The wall.
For like...
How...
Yeah, it's been...
What?
Hahaha!
Baby steps, guys!
Baby steps!
I'll eat healthy...
And then maybe...
By then...
I'll have enough energy...
To...
Construct my bike...
By then.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Um...
Baconator.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Broken bun, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here for no reason, Tokyo.
Tacos burrito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No rice cooker yet.
I mean, now that you guys know my throne.
Actually, no, I shouldn't say that.
I'm worried I get sent, like, four rice cookers.
That's what I'm worried about.
Actually, do not do that.
I don't want to be sent four fucking rice cookers.
Put it up here.
Too late.
Like, what am I going to do?
The doki box, I'll sign...
If I get four rice cookers, I'll sign one of the...
I'll sign three of the rice cooker and then auction it off.
I'll be my own storage.
I'll be my own auctioneer.
That's a lot of rice.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please don't send me five rice cookers, guys.
Um...
Oh, George.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Simple-minded, thank you for the super chat.
I bet it was both.
Only the dragon that bought it knows what color it is.
Will you step up and reveal yourself?
Question mark.
Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're gonna get like 20 rice cookies.
Uh, uh... Kevin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
On the topic of the stream title, a main condition N64 would be so sad because it can't play Metal Gear Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I never owned an N64, uh, to be fair.
But, because it was a Nintendo console, so I never owned one.
I think I owned like a bootleg console that was similar to an N64.
N64.
I don't remember what... No, actually... No, I think I...
No, it wasn't an N64.
It was purple... It was like...
Gray slash purple.
What is that?
It was like... A gray...
It was gray, and then in the middle, it's like...
There's like this purple design in the middle of it.
Um... What was it called?
Is it a Famicom?
Was... Or was it purple?
I don't remember.
No, I had a Famicom!
It wasn't purple.
It was...
Oh, I had a Famicom!
Yeah, I remember this.
Yeah.
I think my...
Dad...
This was my dad's console?
I think?
What... Was...
Was it a Famicom?
It had Bomberman.
It had...
The Bomberman games in it.
Uh...
Anyway, I broke it.
I burned it.
Smoke came out of it.
I didn't burn it.
But like...
Um...
One day...
I was playing...
Bomberman...
On it...
And the smoke came out of the plug.
I shouldn't laugh about it.
But...
Um...
And then...
And then smoke came out.
And I don't think that's supposed...
And then...
It was like...
Dude, that's real...
Damn, that's realism right there.
Was that on the Fam...
Yeah, it was.
It was developed on the...
Oh, it's the Super Famicom!
That's the purple one!
Yeah!
I had...
I had this one!
That's the one that my dad...
Um...
My dad got me.
Or got himself.
Because he played on it.
This was the one.
I remember.
It had...
It had like...
Purple on it.
That's why I remember it.
Because it had purple.
Uh...
Yeah, because we played...
My dad and I would play...
Uh...
Bomberman on this console.
Like the one with the...
Little kangaroos and stuff.
Yeah.
Oh, is that...
When...
Okay, Super...
Okay, what's the difference between...
Oh...
What's the difference between the...
Famicom and the original Famicom?
When did the original...
1983?
Yeah, I didn't have...
Uh...
Yeah, I had this one.
And then like...
One day I was playing Bomberman on it.
Um...
And then smoke came out of the plug sockets.
And then like...
I was freaking...
And then I was like...
Just sitting there looking at it.
And...
Um...
No, it was so...
I don't remember which Bomber...
I love Bomberman.
Because my...
Bomberman was like...
One of my childhood games.
And my dad and I would play...
I would beg my dad to play Bomberman with me all the time.
Because I love Bomberman.
And...
Um...
I love...
I think it was Bomberman 3 and 4 that I played.
Yeah, 3 and 4.
I think 4 was on...
The...
Amicom too, right?
And I would play like 3 and 4 with my dad all the time.
And...
Um...
And it was like...
One of my...
And then like one...
And then...
But I'm pretty sure they were the bootleg version games.
Because I'm pretty sure my dad bought those like...
100 games in one...
I'm pretty sure.
That's what my dad bought.
It was the...
The 100 games in one thing.
I'm...
Yeah, it's like, now that I'm thinking, yeah, now that I'm thinking about it, um, like, we just selected the game from, like, a list.
Like, we didn't, like, swap, we didn't, like, swap, like, uh, the, the cartridges or anything.
Oh, it's an economy.
Oh, it's an economy port, not a mood.
Like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Because I just, I just remembered, like, it was not, like, we didn't, like, swap the game.
And we literally, like, selected it.
Like, because I don't remember, like, ever swapping games.
Yeah, we, I, it was just, um, but one day.
Oh, he caught, right, right, he caught him.
Nothing legal here.
Because I, I, I actually don't remember if we ever swapped it.
Um, what was that Bomberman game where we headed to the carnival?
That one was fun.
Was that also on the carnival game?
Bomberman.
Carnival.
Was that, what, what game was that?
Or was it, like, at the amusement park?
Do you guys remember that Bomberman game where you're at an amusement park?
Bomberman land!
Oh, that one was fun.
It was all in Japanese, but that...
Bomberman land!
Was all in Japanese.
I had no idea how to play this game.
But that game was fun.
I don't know how to play it.
Because, because, like, um, I was so confused.
But it seemed like a fun game.
Because I played it a lot.
I don't know what I was doing.
But it was fun.
Yeah.
I don't even know if it ever got ported into English, guys.
I...
I don't think it was...
Was it ever released in English?
Let's see.
Release.
No, okay.
Yeah, no.
I definitely just played.
I've only just played the English version.
There's only a...
I'm looking.
Yeah.
Japan.
December 21.
Dude, that...
My dad used to do that a lot.
He would, like...
He would buy me...
Like...
Children games.
But they were all in Japanese.
Japanese.
So, like...
I didn't know how to play.
Like...
Oh, my...
I think, like...
Okay.
This...
This is an Asian...
This is definitely, like...
If you're...
Um...
If you're, like...
Chinese...
You might know, like...
These types of stores...
Where, like...
They just sell discs.
You know?
Where...
They just sell...
The discs.
And, like...
I remember...
Growing up...
Um...
My dad would take me to these, like...
Obviously, like...
Gaming stores.
Yeah, like...
Packaging is...
Pricy.
Or worldwide.
Like...
But, like...
It was, like...
These, like...
Like...
Stores that were, like...
Selling...
That were selling games and stuff.
But then you're, like...
Okay, we want...
I don't remember what my dad would say.
But, like...
We're, like...
Oh, we want these...
We want those ones.
And they're, like...
Oh...
And then they, like...
Bring out a giant box...
Of, like...
They'll bring out a giant box of, like...
Like, a cardboard box.
And it's just filled with, like...
Like, different games and stuff.
Like, just a disc.
And, like, clear packaging.
And...
And you just flip through it, and shit like that.
Yeah, it's just the plastic sleeves.
Yeah, Burning Disc was a... Yeah, and then like... And then, but they're like Japanese games, too.
And then... My dad would like, be like, oh, hey, look.
You should be able to buy them for me, because they're... And then, you know, because they'll be like, you have to ask for it.
And they'll just bring it out from under their desk, and it's like, literally... Wait, let me draw it out.
This is like a flashbulb memory that... Like, he would take me to these stores.
And like, literally, like, there's this cardboard box like this.
And then it's like... Filled with... And then you flip through him.
Wait, let me... Okay, you don't see it yet, but I'm drawing it right now.
I just have, like, a memory of that.
But... Alright.
And then, it's like DVDs, too, you know?
Like, I know, like, people do it for DVDs and stuff as well.
But my dad did it for games.
We would buy legit games, though.
We would buy legit English games.
But this is like... I think it was like the only way for my dad to get Chinese games.
Like, games with, like, Chinese subtitles on.
Or he'll just buy the Japanese version.
I'll just buy the Japanese version.
Because, um...
The Japanese version has, like, kanji.
And he... You know, you like...
Kanji has, like, similar Chinese words on it.
So then, like, that was his way of, like, being able to read what's going on.
Yeah, so you can sort of read it.
So, like...
So it looked like this.
You know?
Like, there's the cardboard box.
And then, like, there would be, like, stacks of discs in there.
And you just flip through it.
Like...
Yeah.
You remember those times.
100% disc with a name.
No, but sometimes they would, like...
They would, like...
Print the game on the disc, too.
Or, like, they'll have, like...
They'll have the...
They'll print out a piece of paper with the packaging.
Like, what the game is.
Oh, yeah.
Sweet memories.
Yeah.
They would not...
It won't just be, like, written...
It won't just be a blank disc.
They actually, like...
It was, like...
High quality bootleg.
Where, um...
They actually have, like, the game art on the disc itself.
Or, like...
They'll print out a piece of paper.
Um...
And...
With the packaging.
And be like, this is this game.
Um...
All right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
My dad bought me a...
PSP in China that came with a custom firmware installed and a stack of DVDs with ROMs.
Good times.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat.
100% disc with a name written with marker on bags.
Thank you, Dad and Latin America.
Those games and movies were so fun.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
My- Oh my gosh, that reminds me.
And then, like, um, back then, when I lived in Asia.
Back then, it was so hard because there wasn't any streaming services, actually.
Back then, there wasn't streaming services.
And it's so hard to watch...
Sometimes it's really difficult to watch English movies, too.
So my dad, it was very similar.
My dad would take me to a place...
Where it's also termed like this, but for movies instead.
Like this.
And like...
I remember it was when...
The...
What was that movie?
The Wolverine Origins movie?
The one where...
Ryan Reynolds was in it as...
OG Deadpool?
The OG Deadpool.
And...
But...
When we bought that movie...
It was the version...
That was...
Not finished...
CGI...
At the end.
So I was...
So...
Confused.
I was...
I remember trying to watch this with my dad.
And it was the not finished...
CGI one.
But I was so young...
That I was just like...
What's going on?
I was so confused.
Because it was literally...
Like...
The old...
The green...
Yeah, it was...
I got...
We got...
The actual green screen version...
Copy of that.
And...
I don't know.
I don't know how they got that version of the movie.
It was the...
Post...
It was not...
Not finished CGI one.
That my dad...
And I bought.
I don't know if I still have it.
I don't know.
It might be in some fucking box somewhere.
Like...
Yeah, I got the...
I got the raw edit of it.
Uh...
Amongst, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
You see, you guys laugh about the Minecraft...
Production...
Like pre-production Minecraft movie.
But back then...
I...
Had the...
I had the...
X-Men Origins Wolverine version.
Where Deadpool is like...
Fully CGI.
On top of a fucking...
Like...
It was so weird.
He...
I...
I like...
Remember it vaguely.
But...
It was a scene where he was just CGI.
On top of like...
Some fucking...
Like...
I guess like...
Disc or some shit.
And also...
Cause it was like...
It like...
It was at the end.
It was like...
Everything looked okay.
Until the last...
Like...
30 minutes.
Where it was just all CGI.
Like...
It was...
It was unfinished CGI.
Like...
You don't know...
It was so normal.
Until then.
Um...
NSD.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you're gonna...
Bring up that Deadpool...
I gotta ask...
Why the hell...
I gotta go out streaming services...
Doing in a school.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
No?
Oh, he wants food early.
It's not...
Ready.
Um...
I don't remember how my dad reacted to it.
I just remember being so fucking confused.
Um...
But yeah.
I think like...
Back then too.
I think it was cause like...
Uh...
Back then.
I don't know if people know about this.
Um...
But...
The only way you can buy...
Actual like...
Games too.
Back then.
When I used to live in Asia.
Like when I used to...
Also like when I used to live in China.
Was in...
Hong Kong.
Um...
Cause I...
You guys...
I told you guys before.
But I used to live in Shenzhen as well.
And...
Uh...
When I lived in Shenzhen.
Consoles back then.
I don't know if they changed the law.
Where like...
You can't get consoles back then.
Because of the laws.
Uh...
Because...
Um...
You can only buy like...
Uh...
Consoles made in China.
Cause they did have like their own type of consoles.
But...
You can't...
Um...
Have like...
You can't buy, like, PlayStations or Xbox 360s and stuff like that.
So it was a lot harder to get games as well if you do own the consoles.
And so because of that, the only way to get, like, the actual games itself is if you go to Hong Kong to buy them.
Or you go to the underground market.
Does anyone remember the underground gaming market?
Like, I remember when my dad would take me there.
And they're like...
Yeah, and it was just all, like, you know, PC stuff you can buy.
And everything, like, the legit games.
But then they have, like, you know, the special box.
The special box.
Alright, let me pick him.
Maybe if I pick him up.
Oh.
Alright.
He's on my lap.
He's barking too much.
He's barking too much!
So he's on my lap right now.
My head, what is that?
Yeah.
Forget him.
Since he's on my lap.
I'll let you guys see him.
There you go.
Class president is here now.
We have Mr. Class President.
He's a naughty boy.
But let me...
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me make it so you guys can action.
So he's not cut off.
Uh...
Alright.
There you go.
It was a different time back then.
Um...
No.
No barking.
No barking, Mr. Class President.
Uh...
Oh yeah!
I can have him on my...
Oh my god, you're right!
What's happening?
I forgot about that.
It's been so long.
Where is it?
Give me a sec.
Get out of here!
I'm gonna put down my phone.
There you go.
Yay!
There he is.
Mr. Class President.
Um...
But I don't know.
Is it still the same?
It's easier now, right?
They changed the...
laws, right?
I'm pretty sure it's a lot easier now.
Um...
But...
Yeah.
There he is.
Um...
But yeah, that's what I...
It just brought back memories and stuff.
Yeah.
Much easier.
That's good to know.
Um...
Let's see.
I saw...
Doki, I saw the same unfinished Wolverine movie.
Thank you for the super chat, Monks.
Thank you.
Uh...
Let's see.
Jay...
Uh...
LeCone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What surprised me is that...
I revisited one of the shops when seeing family in Hong Kong.
And they're still doing a brisk trade even in the modern digital era.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's funny.
That's silly thing.
Um...
I feel like cause like now that Steam is more accessible, and it's a lot easier now to get games these days, that I feel like, you know, people don't have to do this anymore.
Cause like for...
Like back then, when I was growing up, it was more so like the lack of accessibility.
You know?
It was just harder to...
Like...
Play the games that we wanted to play.
Cause like I try to...
You know...
Every...
I do try...
I try...
I...
Um...
We traveled a lot to Hong Kong so I can buy like video games and stuff too.
Well, I try to buy video games and movies that I wanna watch.
Yeah, it used to be like the only option because of accessibility.
Yeah.
I think that's why Spotify was invented.
I don't know if you guys know this.
I...
I recently found out Spotify was...
Was made by...
The Swedish?
I think?
Was it the Swedish that invented Spotify?
Um...
But...
That's why like piracy only comes about when things are not accessible.
Basically...
I recently learned that...
This lore...
About Spotify.
But...
Um...
Back then...
Pirate Bay was everywhere.
And people were just like...
What was it?
Pirate Bay or LimeWire songs that that one...
Or Torrent songs and stuff.
To listen to their songs.
And then...
Um...
Pirate Bay went through like several lawsuits.
Because like...
You know...
From music producers and music...
Music label companies.
Because people were like...
You're taking away...
Money from the...
Um...
From the artists!
When they're mostly taking money away from...
Uh...
From music label companies.
Because music label companies are like a scam sometimes.
But...
But that was back then.
I think they're a lot better now.
But I know like back then...
Music label companies were like...
Very predatory.
But they're like...
I think they're a lot better now.
I don't know.
I know they went through a lot of lawsuits.
Especially with the whole Kesha situation.
So I heard they're a lot better now.
Obviously, they're still pretty predatory.
But anyway, funny fact.
The reason why Spotify came to be was because people were... got tired of pirating stuff because they're like... they're like... people were like... the people who developed Spotify was like, why pirate when the free version, the legal version, is a lot easier and more accessible.
And that's why Spotify blew up.
Because people, in general, they would rather... if there was an... if it was legal and it was easier to access, then people would get it legally.
But because of the... because things are... when things aren't accessible, then they have to turn to the option of pirating.
And that's why Spotify became like, you know, the gigantic multi-million dollar company that it is today.
Because, like, it was just... easier to listen to it legally and buying a subscription... than, um... than just, like, doing it illegally and stuff.
Yeah.
Yeah, they didn't know what the legal version needed to reach and lock and go back to downloading... yeah, that's so true.
Um...
Yeah, it's also why piracy dropped that scene became popular in video games.
And why piracy picked up again when publishers started attacking...
like, accesses and ownership and such.
I'm not surprised.
Like I said, like, um... usually people pirate only because, like, it's just things that aren't, like, easily accessible.
Um... it's just, like... just a pattern, in general.
Uh...
Lotta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm regionblocked from... oof.
That sucks.
Um... even then, I just listen to...
I don't... I don't...
use Spotify, really.
Because, like, for me...
Um...
I mostly listen to instrumental music when I'm working.
Because, like, I have no time...
Like, when I listen to music, what...
So, like...
I just YouTube, like, a playlist of instrumental music when I'm working.
So, like, I normally...
I don't normally use Spotify.
Uh...
And then, what about my phone?
Well, my phone is filled with...
I used to buy albums and stuff, back then.
Um...
So, my phone is just filled with, like...
Legally owned...
Legally owned music.
That I actually bought.
Um...
And also, like...
Tumblr songs that I downloaded.
That may not be legal, but...
That may or may not be legal, but, like...
It's there.
Back when...
Tumblr had a music player.
And you'd be like, Oh, that's a funky song that people made.
To be fair, they were mostly, like, mashups, you know?
I don't remember if people remember those times on Tumblr.
Um...
But, there were a lot of, like...
Like, there was a phase.
There was a fad.
Where people were mashing up songs together.
And posting it on Tumblr.
And, like...
There were some really, really good ones.
I think, like, one of my favorite ones...
Um...
There was one where it was...
It was Daft Punk and Steven Universe.
Let me see if I can pull it up.
I remember...
That one was from Tumblr.
Uh...
I actually have it on my phone, too.
Okay.
Daft Punk...
Steven...
Universe.
It's actually really...
Oh, it's here.
This one.
I think it was this one.
Yeah.
This one...
I have this one on my playlist.
There's the one I remember.
That was a mashup.
And then there was that...
Um...
Oh, there's the other one with Daft Punk.
And it was with...
Another anime song.
What was it?
It's, uh...
Mmm...
I remember I showed it to you guys on stream before.
It was...
Get Lucky with...
With another...
With an anime song.
Get Lucky mashup.
What was it?
It was so good.
No, no, no, no, no.
It was an anime song.
With Get Lucky.
I don't know...
Is it on YouTube?
I hope it's on YouTube.
I have it on my phone.
But I don't know if it's on YouTube.
Get Lucky.
Get Lucky mashup.
Uh...
What was it?
Does anyone remember?
It was Get Lucky with another song.
Does anyone remember which song?
Does anyone like...
Does anyone remember it?
It was with an anime song.
It was with a Japanese song.
And I know I showed it on stream before.
Alright, are you calm now?
Are you calm?
Just sitting on my lap.
Like, chilling on my lap.
Okay?
Calm now, right?
Yeah?
You're satisfied?
I swear to God, if he starts barking.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna, like...
Stop moving for a sec.
Because I'm gonna check my phone.
Because I do have it on my phone.
So maybe I can find it.
Okay.
I know I have it.
Uh...
Is it even called Get Lucky?
Is it not?
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Is it...
Is it this one?
Oh, is it this one?
Okay, I'm worried that, like...
I wonder if it's this one.
Is it Get Lucky?
It has to be Get Lucky, right?
I'm pretty sure it was Get Lucky.
Unless it was another one.
Daft Punk.
Mashup.
Anime.
If all fails, put anime at the bottom.
I swear to God, it was another song?
It could be.
I don't know.
Now I'm, like...
Now I'm doubting myself.
I'm Get Lucky Kiki Slider.
Okay.
I'm looking at my library.
Just to see if I can find it.
Songs.
Show me Daft Punk songs in my phone.
Oh my God.
I have Megalovania versus Harder, Better, Faster, Stronger.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha Dad's being an asshole right now.
I guess we'll never know.
It was so good, though.
Okay.
I know it was really cute.
It was a really good song.
I can't remember it on the top of my head.
I'm looking through my phone, too.
I think he just wants to be fed earlier.
Is this one?
Okay.
No!
He just... No, he just wants to be... He just wants to be fed early.
He's a... Wait, is this?
Oh my god, I'm like, looking through my playlist to try and find this.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'll never find it.
It's lost in history.
It was a... It was cute.
It was a cute song, too.
I know it was Daft Punk.
So, I'm like, what happened?
Where did it go?
Was Get Lucky the only...
Wait, let me double check.
Get Lucky is a song by...
What album was it?
It wasn't Lose Yourself to Dance.
It was with Pharrell Williams.
I know it was...
This is what...
Yeah, it's so...
Maybe it got re...
Maybe.
I don't know.
I don't know if it got removed or not.
Mashup.
I just knew it was like...
It was really good.
That's all I remember.
It was with an anime...
It was with a Japanese song, too.
But...
I can't seem to find it on my...
On my playlist.
I don't know.
Oh, well.
Maybe one day.
Maybe one day I'll find it.
For now.
For now it'll be lost in time.
I know I...
I know I showed it on stream before.
A long time ago.
I know I...
I remember I showed it on stream.
So I don't know if any lore masters...
Remember it.
I can't remember.
One day...
One of us will remember.
One day, guys.
I know one of us will remember.
Actual lost media.
You know what's a classic, though?
Oops.
Classic.
Like...
The classic is the Snoop Dog...
The Snoop Dog...
Bittersweet song.
Snoop Dog...
Sugar...
Spice...
A surprise.
Snoop Dog...
Surprise...
Song...
Snoop Dogg, Mashup.
I want to listen to that song again.
What was it called?
Does anyone remember what that song was called?
Blend?
Yeah, Blend W.
That's a classic.
I love the internet.
A true classic.
Surprise?
What does this say?
Surprise!
I love the song.
If I could, I'll sing this at a concert.
I hope one day I can sing this at a concert.
Did you know?
Did you know the co-founder of Yishoujo made this video?
Did you guys...
Did you guys know that?
The co-founder of Yishoujo actually made this shitpost.
Yeah, that's so wild.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, Jesus He or she, how?
Yeah,
I don't know.
He's totally okay.
We will sing...
But he's too much.
Mom goes again!
I think that's like... Honestly, that's like a classic.
Anyway, guys... Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call it here because we have another stream later today.
I didn't make the waiting room for it yet.
So, I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me, everybody!
All right, guys, I had a fun time!
Dad's just me, little asshole, because he wants to be fed an hour early.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer me, head to bed, because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everyone!
Bye, guys!
Oh, my God, he got closer!
He's, like, outside my door now!
All right, bye, guys!
Bye!